FOR OUR SELECT COMMITTEE ON STEM
WE'RE GOING TO WORKING ON
CHANGING THE NAME OF THIS
COMMITTEE. TO STEAM BECAUSE WE
THINK THAT ARTS PLAYS A CRITICAL
ROLE IN OUR CONVERSATION ABOUT
PREPARING STUDENTS FOR THE
FUTURE.
.
AND IF I DISAGREE WITH CALLING
IT SEEMS THAT A STEM.
WELL I WISH YOU COULD GO BACK
AND NATION A WELCOME TO OUR
HEARING.
PLEASE BE JOINED BY OUR
COLLEAGUES WILL BE MAKING SOME
REMARKS IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
I'M MY NAME IS TONY THURMOND I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF SHARING OUR
STEM COMMITTEE. UP WE WANT TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
IT TAKES TO PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
THE JOBS OF TOMORROW.
HOW WE ALIGN EDUCATION HOW TO
REALIGN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE HOW
WE MAKE SURE THE GETTING THE
RIGHT EXPERIENCES?
HOW WE TALK ABOUT DIVERSITY IN
THE WORKFORCE HOW DO WE ADD TO
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR FOR WOMEN? AND FOR OTHERS
TO BE INVOLVED IN JOBS OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE KNOW WILL
SUPPORT OUR ECONOMY SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SUPPORT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK
IN THEM IN THEIR ABILITY TO WORK
IN THEIR FAMILIES
ALSO WE ARE PLEASED IT YOU'RE
HERE TODAY.
TO JOIN US FOR THIS
CONVERSATION I'M WE HAVE
SEVERAL.
IMPRESSIVE SPEAKERS TODAY.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WERE BEEN
ASSET EVERYBODY GIVE KIND OF A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW. SO WE CAN
SAY THE MAJORITY THE TIME FOR
CONVERSATION IN QUESTION AND
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHERE WE NEED
TO GO NEXT.
SO HAVING SAID THAT ALLOW ME TO
WELCOME YOU HOW I TURNED OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON WHO MAKE A FEW REMARKS
AT THE.
THANK.
S. A DELIGHT TO BE WITH YOU.
HERE TODAY AND.
TO SHARE THAT PASSION THAT YOU
HAVE FOR EDUCATION AND
SPECIFICALLY TODAY TO HEAR ABOUT
US STEM OR SHALL WE SAY STEAM.
AND.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING.
ABOUT AND AND ONE OF THOSE.
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE THAT
THAT.
KINDA RULES OVER MY MIND IS THE
IS THE EFFORT THAT IS BEING MADE
IN THE EDUCATION UNIVERSE.
ON HOW WE ARE ADDRESSING.
SHALL I SAY STEEN BUT WE WE AS.
THE CHAIR AND I COME FROM A
REGION.
THAT IS CONSIDERED TO BE OF THE
GLOBAL LEADER IN TECHNOLOGY THAT
PUTS A DEMAND UP ON A WORK FORCE
THAT REQUIRES TRAINING IN
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGICAL ANALOGY
ENGINEERING MATH. AND INCLUDING
THE ARTS.
AND SO WITH THAT WHAT EFFORTS.
ARE HAPPENING WITH IN THE
EDUCATION UNIVERSE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE MEETING THE NEEDS
THAT EXIST IN OUR IN OUR REGIONS
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND SPECIFICALLY FROM WHERE I'M
COMING FROM. THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT I I KNOW WAS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF MY MIND IS ACCESS
TO STEM.
AND WHEN I TALK ABOUT ACCESS TO
STEM WHETHER IT'S AN A FLUENT.
SCHOOL DISTRICT VERSUS ON
UNDERSERVED OR WHETHER IT'S.
THE GENDER DISPARITY OR EVEN IN
RACE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL YOU HAVE.
FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS FAR ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS STEM EDUCATION
AND THEN THE ANOTHER ISSUE THE
PRESSES.
MY MIND WOULD BE BAD THE ISSUE
WHERE THE BUSINESS AND EMPLOYER
SECTOR HAVE ACCESS TO A POOL OF
WORKERS THAT HAVE BEEN WELL
TRAINED WELL EQUIPPED. AND ARE
READY TO WORK.
IN A STEM ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN EDUCATED AND
TRAINED IN A STEM ENVIRONMENT
SO.
LOOKING FOR TO HEARING YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY FROM THE EXPERTS.
THANK YOU SIMILAR GRAYSON FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO STAND INTO
STEAM ALSO WERE HONORED TO BE
JOINED BY COLLEAGUE WHO'S BEEN A
LEADER ON ISSUES RELATED TO
TECHNOLOGY.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
IN REMARKS
AFTER LISTENING TO MICHELLE
PULPIT YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I. WANT TO START OFF BY
THANKING YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
OPENING TO SELL HEARING
TOGETHER.
ARE IN FACT JUST YESTERDAY I HAD
A HEARING ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE A WHICH IS ACTUALLY
SOMETHING THAT PROMISES TO
TRANSFORM THE WORK.
PLACES SO IN THE FUTURE. AND
OUT ONE OF THINGS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT WAS A. YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
PREPARE OUR. AFFORD THIS
TRANSFORMATION AND ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS WAS THAT WE NEED TO
TRAIN OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. ARE IN A
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND STEM
RELATED FIELD AND AND THAT'S THE
VERY ESSENCE OF STEM AND THAT.
THE RELEVANCE OF TODAY'S
HEARING SO I'M REALLY EXCITED TO
BE HERE I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PRESENTERS FOR JOINING US TODAY
AND. BEFORE TO YOUR TESTIMONIES
IS OFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OUT OF WE
HAVE.
A NUMBER OF PANELISTS TODAY.
WILL BE JOINED BY MEMBERS.
AS ABLE TO ON THEIR NUMBER OF
PRESENTATIONS.
PROTESTS PROCLAMATIONS YOU NAME
IT THEY'RE ALL HAPPENING.
AND SO MEMBERS WILL KIND OF
COME IN AND OUT AS THEY ARE ABLE
TO.
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM ALL OF YOU AND.
BEFORE FIRST PANEL OUT WERE
HONORED ON TO HAVE THE PRESIDENT
OF CAL STATE EAST BAY DOCTOR THE
WAY MORISHITA.
WE'RE ALSO HONORED TO HAVE THE
EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE INSTITUTE
FOR STEM EDUCATION TRINA
OSTRANDER.
THE DEAN OF THE COLLEGE OF
EDUCATION AT CAL STATE EAST BAY
DR CAROLYN NELSON. AND FROM THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WEBER EDUCATORS DONALD
CONNOR OF THAT WELCOME AND WITH
THAT I GOT MORE SHEET IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR THURMOND AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON STEAM EDUCATION.
GLAD TO BE HERE I'M HERE MARIE
STEP PRESIDENT CAL STATE EAST
BAY. AND SO YOU MAY WONDER WHY
IS A PRESIDENT OF A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY HERE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT SEEM EDUCATION AND THE
URGENCY OF IMPROVING. MATH
EDUCATION FOR PRESCHOOLERS.
EVERY YEAR MANY STUDENTS ARRIVE
AT CAL STATE EAST BAY.
UNPREPARED FOR MATHEMATICS.
AND WE NEED TO SEE IF WE CAN
HELP THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE
STRUGGLE TAKES THEM EXTRA TIME
EXTRA EFFORT. IN LONGER AND MORE
EXPENSE.
CAN CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION.
AND I'M HERE BECAUSE CAL STATE
EAST BAY IS AT THE CENTER OF A
REGIONAL ECOSYSTEM.
THAT IS WORKING TO FIND WAYS TO
SUCCESSFULLY PREPARE. ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS
AND FOR US TO DELIVER ON THAT
MESSAGE.
OUR RESEARCH IN PRACTICE HAS
PROVEN THAT WHEN WE START EARLY.
WE CAN CLEAR AWAY A LOT OF THE
BARRIERS THAT OUR STUDENTS FIND
ALONG THEIR PATH TO COLLEGE AND
CAREERS IN THE FIELDS. OF THEIR
CHOOSING.
SO CAL STATE EAST BAY HAS BECOME
A LEADER IN STEM EDUCATION AS A
MATTER OF EQUITY AND
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR OUR STUDENTS
WHO COMPRISE THE MOST DIVERSE
PUBLIC FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY. IN
THE CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES.
AND WE STRIVE TO DELIVER A
REGIONAL WORKFORCE AS YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THAT POWERS ARE
INNOVATIVE INCREASINGLY STEM
BASED ECONOMY.
WHAT MANY PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
IS THAT IN ADDITION TO SERVING
OUR STUDENTS THE C. ISSUES ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES ARE
CHARGED HIM HEARING CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS? TKA
THROUGH FOURTEEN BOTH IN SERVICE
AND UNDERGRADS.
IN THESE DUAL ROLES CASTING EAST
BAY HAS BEEN ENGAGED FOR YEARS
IN INNOVATIVE COLLABORATION TO
BIG STRONG STEM EDUCATION TO OUR
DIVERSE REGIONS.
ONE OF THESE IS THE SPACE STEM
NETWORK.
ACROSS SECTOR COLLABORATION WITH
EDUCATORS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INDUSTRY
LEADERS AND POLICY MAKERS.
THE NETWORK BEGAN ITS INNOVATIVE
WORK IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WITH
A ROAD MAP TO STUDENT SUCCESS.
HONING IN ON FOR PRIORITIES.
EARLY EDUCATION.
OUT OF SCHOOL TIME.
STUDIES PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR TEACHERS
IN HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE
TRANSITIONS.
TODAY'S RECOMMENDATIONS SIGNED
BY LEADERS IN EDUCATION INDUSTRY
AND OUR COMMUNITIES
CAME OUT OF THE NETWORK'S EARLY
EDUCATION WORKING GROUP.
THESE EXPERTS EXAMINE THE
COMPELLING RESEARCH.
SHOWING THE PROFOUND IMPORTANCE
OF EARLY MATH TWO ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT IN ALL DISCIPLINES.
THEY CONVENE CONFERENCES AND
ISSUE REPORTS WHICH HAVE BEGUN
TO HAVE IMPACT AMONG TEACHERS
AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO TODAY WE'RE HERE TO BE BRING
TO YOU THIS KNOWLEDGE.
HOPING FOR SYSTEMIC CHANGE TO
BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT MATH DEFEAT
DEFICITS.
THAT EXIST UPON ENTRY INTO
KINDERGARTEN.
CAN BE OVERCOME QUICKLY.
WITH LASTING EFFECTS.
OUR WORK WITH THE HE WOULD
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT TODAY.
AS PUT THIS RESEARCH INTO
PRACTICE
THE REAL RESULTS ARE VERY VERY
EXCITING.
WE'RE PLEASED WE JOINED TODAY BY
COLLEAGUES.
TOGETHER WE ARE BUILDING IN AND
DURING.
NETWORK DEVOTED TO APPEARING
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS FOR THE
STEAM CAREERS THAT DRIVE OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY.
WITH YOUR LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT
WE CAN MAKE A WELL PAYING STEM
CAREER REALITY FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. WHO SO
CHOOSE THIS PATH
BANKING?
THANK YOU DOCTOR MARIE SHOULD I
AND I I APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT WHY WOULD PRESIDENT BE
HERE.
Y. WITH THE PRESIDENT BE HERE
IN A SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT YOU
BEING HERE IN THE DEAN BEING
HERE. AND THE COMMITMENTS OF RC
ISSUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SUCH AND THERE CERTAINLY
SOMEONE'S BEEN NO STRANGER TO
HELPING YOUNG PEOPLE PREPARE FOR
JOBS AND TECHNOLOGY AND HEALTH
CARE. BIOTECH WE WELCOME YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HEARING
FOR CALLING THE SKY CONFERENCE
TOGETHER. I'M. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT
THE MATH POLICY STATEMENT THAT
HAS COME OUT OF THE EAST BAY
STEM. NETWORK BY AS DOCTOR
MARCIA EXPLAINED THE NETWORK IS
A CROSS SECTORAL. OF
COLLABORATION THAT'S BEEN
WORKING I'M FOR WHAT THE LAST
SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS. I AM ON
DELIVERING QUALITY STEM
EDUCATION STEAM EDUCATION TO
OUR.
ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE COUNTRY
PRIDE REGIONS IN THE COUNTRY.
SO THERE ARE POLICY STATEMENT IS
THAT A PROCESS THAT A PRODUCT OF
YEARS OF WORK IN COLLABORATION
AND STUDY AND RESEARCH AND
ACTIVISM.
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS IT SHOULD BE
IN PACKETS YOU HAVE AND WE HAVE
HARD COPIES FOR ANYBODY WHO
WANTS.
MORE I'M JUST GOING TO WALK YOU
THROUGH IT VERY BRIEFLY AND THEN
TURN IT OVER TO SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO CAN TELL YOU
ABOUT HOW THESE PRACTICES. HAVE
ACTUALLY WORKED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
FIRST WE START WITH WHY IS
EARLY NOW IMPORTANT SOME PEOPLE
SEEM TO THINK THAT IT'S NOT AS
IMPORTANT AS THINGS LIKE
LITERACY. AND IT'S REALLY KEY
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS ONE IS
MATH PROFICIENCY AT KINDERGARTEN
HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE AS
IMPORTANT A PREDICTOR OF EARLY
OF FUTURE ACADEMIC SUCCESS. IN
ALL DISCIPLINES AS LITERACY.
ARE AND YET IT'S TAUGHT A
FRACTION OF THE AMOUNT.
BY KINDERGARTEN THERE'S ALREADY
A DEMONSTRATED ACHIEVEMENT GAP
GUESS WHAT CORRELATED TO THINGS
LIKE INCOME AND.
ETHNIC.
I BACKGROUND AND THOSE KINDS OF
SOCIO ECONOMIC FACTORS. THE GAP
FIVE STARTS OUT A KINDERGARTEN
AT TWENTY MONTHS
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT KIDS WHO
ARE LIKE SIXTEEN MONTHS OLD. AND
THEY'VE GOT A TWENTY MONTH.
HANDICAP WHEN THEY WHEN THEY
GET TO FORMAL SCHOOLING KELLY
GETS WORSE AS STUDENTS WHO FLEW
WITH.
A.
A MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL UNPREPARED. AS
DOCTOR ARISTA POINTED OUT FOR
COLLEGE LEVEL MATH.
I THIS COST THEM TIME AND MONEY
IS BOMB SOME OUT THEY GET
DEPRESSED AND OFTEN THAT'S.
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR IN NOT
COMPLETING THE FOUR YEAR DEGREE
IN SIX YEARS OR ANY OTHER NUMBER
OF YEARS.
I AS W KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY IS DRIVEN BY STEM STEAM
BASED INDUSTRIES. THEIR ONE
MILLION ENTRY LEVEL JOBS YEAH
REQUIRE IT IN STEAM.
.
DISCIPLINES COMING UP WITHIN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE EMPLOYERS WHO'VE SIGNED ON
TO OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
PROVIDE AMPLE TESTIMONY ABOUT
THE.
I COME FROM BAYER CORPORATION
YOU KNOW AND LEAD SORT OF
CHARACTERIZE IT AS STARVATION
MODE THAT EMPLOYERS ARE AND. FOR
LOCAL TALENT ESPECIALLY IN A
HIGH COST OF LIVING AREA LIKE
THAT'S.
I AND FINALLY CALIFORNIA RANKS
AT THE BOTTOM THE HOUSE FOR
YEARS. AYE FOR THINGS LIKE
ENGINEERING AND COMPUTER SCIENCE
DEGREE COMPLETION ESPECIALLY
AMONG STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND WE
OBVIOUSLY NEED TO FIX THAT
AND WE CAN'T.
SO I A BRIEF SUMMARY OF THE
ACTUAL POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
WINE IS TO BEGIN BY LAUNCHING A
BROAD PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF EARLY
MATH EDUCATION. AND HOW FUN IT
CAN BE ARE AND HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS IS A FACTOR IN FUTURE ADULTS
SUCCESS.
I DO TOO IS PROVIDE PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS WITH AFFORDABLE MATH
EDUCATION RESOURCE SINCE. ARM
AND AGAIN THAT ARE FUN MATH
EDUCATION THAT AN EARLY AGE IS
FUN. AYE TRACK I MEAN I'M AN
ENGLISH MAJOR BUT IT MIGHT EVEN
BE MORE FUN THAN LITERACY SO.
GET WAY THAT YOU'VE GOT TO TELL
PEOPLE THAT THEY DON'T KNOW IT
BUT THAT'S THE POINT OF THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO GET THAT
WORD OUT.
AND FINALLY IT'S IN THIS GETS A
LITTLE MORE COMPLEX BUT WE CAN
DO IT. BY INCREASINGLY
UNDERSTANDING AND EXPERTISE OF
EARLY EDUCATION PROVIDERS ARM
AND THAT'S STARTING IN PRESCHOOL
AND CHILDCARE.
IT MEANS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS. ARE IT
MEANS RETHINKING CREDENTIALING
REQUIREMENTS IN INCENTIVIZING
PARTICIPATION. IT MEANS
INSTITUTING MOSCOW'S ASSESSMENTS
OF STUDENTS EARLY ON SO THAT WE
CAN TELL WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHERE THE GAPS NEED.
TO BE FILLED.
.
I THINK IT LEAVES ONE MORE
THING.
I KNOW BECAUSE IT'S SO THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE START. I DO
NOT THIS COMPLETE SOLUTION TO
STEM EDUCATION WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT MAYBE AT SOME OTHER FUTURE
MEETING BUT THEY'RE DOABLE AND
WOOD HEALED YOU ARE MISS RESULTS
FOR STUDENTS IN ALL. AREAS OF
STUDY.
SEAN HOW IT WORKS.
REGULAR SESSION AND THERE'D BE
NELSON. LOOK YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS SHARE
WITH YOU WHAT IT DOES TAKE. TO
MAKE THIS WORK AND TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AT SOME SCALE FOR.
FOR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES.
HE WOULD PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD
FOR WHICH I'M THAT THE PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR. IS A CRADLE TO
CAREER CROSS SECTOR PARTNERSHIP
LED BY CAL STATE EAST BAY WHOSE
PRIMARY PURPOSE IS TO ALLEVIATE
THE ADVERSE EFFECTS OF POVERTY.
OF FOUR OUT COMES.
OUTCOMES FOR FAMILIES THAT ARE
UNDERSERVED TYPICALLY.
AND AS THE LEAD AGENCY CSU EAST
BAY COORDINATES ACTIVITIES
SILICATES MEETINGS MONITORS
PROTOCOLS. PRODUCT PERFORMS DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS AND AS A
PARTNER.
WE ALSO PROVIDE SERVICES BY
ENGAGING OUR GREATEST ASSETS
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR FACULTY.
THROUGH OUR THROUGH OUR SERVICE
LEARNING INTERNSHIPS THAT WE
OFFER THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
AND WE ALSO PROVIDE COMMUNITY
COUNSELING CLINIC SERVICES FOR
AND ONE OF THE AREAS THAT IS THE
MOST CHALLENGING FOR UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS.
BOB MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
SO.
WE ARE A PARTNER AS WELL AS THE
LEAD AGENCY.
HEY REPUBLIC STABLE HOOD IS THE
COMMUNITY BASED INITIATIVE THAT
RECEIVED A PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD
AWARD IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
AND WE WERE WHEN THE FIRST FIVE
INITIATIVES IN THE COUNTRY WE
WERE THE ONLY PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
TO LEAD ONE OF THE AWARDS.
SO I THINK THAT A PART OF IT HAD
A LOT OF FAITH IN THE COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS THE UNIVERSITY
WEREN'T SURE IF UNIVERSITIES
SHOULD BE ENGAGED IN THIS WORK I
SAY. UNIVERSITIES MUST BE
ENGAGED IN THIS WORK THIS IS THE
WORK.
OF EDUCATION.
A.
WE'RE ALSO.
LET'S SEE WE ENDED THIS GRANT
IN DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
THE DATA THAT I'M GOING TO SHOW
YOU TODAY IS FROM THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS.
OF OUR WORK WE HAD A TRANSITION
YEAR.
AND BASED ON THE COMMITMENT OF
OUR PARTNERS WE ALL WE ALL HUNG
TOGETHER APPLIED FOR ANOTHER
AWARD AND RECEIVED THE GOOD NEWS
JERRY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT
WE WERE A SECOND A WORDY. TO
SCALE UP THE WORK TO A NEW
NEIGHBORHOOD UP THREE SENSES
CAME UP THREE CENSUS BLOCK AREA.
THAT IT'S IN THE TENNIS AND
QUARTER NOW.
SO BUT I BELIEVE THE SUCCESS OF
THIS WORK
IS DUE IN PART TO THE
INTENTIONALITY OF THE
COLLABORATIVE HAD.
TO WORK DIFFERENTLY TOGETHER.
NOW WE'VE HAD COLLABORATIVE AND
GRANT AWARDS FOR DECADES.
BUT WHAT IS IT DIFFERENT ABOUT
THIS IS WHAT WE TELL YOU WHAT IS
TO TRADITIONAL.
USUALLY PARTNERS ARE GIVEN AN
AWARD EVEN IF YOU REQUIRE
COLLABORATION THERE GIVEN AN
AWARD. AND THEN EVERY PARTNER
GOES OFF
PERFORMS ITS SERVICES PROVIDES
ITS IT SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY
AND MAYBE THEY'LL MEASURE IT AND
THEN PEOPLE OFTEN WORK THE SAME
AS IF THEY HAD NEVER BEEN
TOGETHER.
AND SO WE HAVE WHICH A TYPICALLY
HAVE IS PROVIDING INTERVENTIONS
THAT ONLY HAVE ISOLATED IMPACT.
OKAY AND AND WHAT WE HAVE REALLY
WORKED HARD TO DO.
IS CREATE COLLECTIVE IMPACT
AS AN ORGANIZATION OF THE
COLLABORATIVE TO PERFORM LARGE
SCALE.
SOCIAL CHANGE NOT TO PERFORM IT
TO ENABLE IT.
OKAY. AND THE SEARCHING THROUGH
THE STRATEGIC COORDINATION OF
SERVICES. MUTUALLY REINFORCING
ACTIVITIES
AND ALIGNMENT OF SOLUTIONS
RATHER THAN DUPLICATION OF
SOLUTIONS
BECAUSE ALL OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE NOW PART
OF THIS WORK WE STARTED WITH TEN
THE FIRST FIVE YEARS. WE'RE NOW
UP TO FOURTEEN.
AND THIS NEW BODY OF WORK
SOME OTHER FOR OUR FUNDED SOME
OF THEM ARE NOT.
BUT THEY'VE ALL COMMITTED TO
SHARING DATA. THEY'VE ALL
COMMITTED TO REVIEWING THE DATA.
AND WE SHARE THE DATA WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THEY'RE TELLING US WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT ISN'T.
BUT OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE.
IS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE FOR
COMMUNICATION SUPPORT
ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS THE
PIPELINE.
AND WHERE WHERE THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION OCCURS ACROSS THE
NETWORKS.
SO THIS IS COLLABORATION WITH
THE CAPITAL CITY.
ON THE BILL EARLY LEARNING
NETWORK IS ONE OF OUR WORK ON
NETWORKS THAT HAS DATA THAT I
WILL BE SHARING WITH YOU IN JUST
A SECOND. THE SECOND NETWORK IS
OUR CRADLE TO CAREER EDUCATIONAL
REFORM NETWORK AND THE THIRD
WORK NETWORK IS THE NEIGHBORHOOD
HEALTH AND EMPOWERMENT NETWORK.
WHERE EACH NETWORK IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADDRESSING ONE
OR MORE OF OUR TENT OUTCOMES
BENCHMARK BY FIFTEEN INDICATORS?
PARTNER MEETINGS INCLUDING OUR
ADVISORY BOARD WHICH IS
PRIMARILY MADE UP PARENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY COALESCE.
AROUND DATA.
AND THE IMPACT OF THE SERVICES
OFFERED.
INSTEAD OF SAYING THIS IS MY
FAVORITE SERVICE SO YOU HAVE TO
LIKE IT. WERE AFTER HIM DO THAT
WORKING AND SO WE CENTER OUR
CONVERSATIONS AROUND A RESULTS
BASED ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK
THAT ADDRESSES THE FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS.
HOW MUCH DID IT TO?
HOW WELL DID WE DO IT?
AND BY THE WAY IS ANYBODY BETTER
OFF.
THAT'S A KEY QUESTION THAT'S
OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION.
SO.
LET'S SEE JUST IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME LET ME JUST.
JUMPED TO THE PERCENT OF
INTERNS O..
BARTLETT EARLY LEARNING NETWORK
I THINK IS PART OF YOUR PACKET.
YOU HAVE SOME INFO GRAPHICS BUT
I'D LIKE TO JUST HIGHLIGHT IT
WON'T READ EVERYTHING ON THERE
TO YOUR POINT OUT EVERYTHING.
IN YOUR SPARE TIME.
ASSUMING YOU EVER HAD ANY YOU
COULD TAKE A LOOK AT THESE BUT I
THINK THEY SPEAK LOUDLY ABOUT.
THE KEY.
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS WORKING
DIFFERENTLY TOGETHER LEVERAGING
EACH OTHER'S WORK LEVERAGING
EACH OTHER'S MONEY NO WE DON'T
ALL HAVE TO PERFORM THE SAME
ACTIVITY WEEP? WE PERFORM
INTERVENTIONS THAT WORK BEST AND
WHAT WE'RE GOOD AT RATHER THAN
RECREATING THE WHEEL ACROSS ALL
PARTNERS.
NOT SO TRADITIONAL THAT IS SO
TYPICAL OF WHAT HAPPENS TO IT
FOR GRANT MONEY IN OUR FEES.
OKAY SO TAKE A LOOK AT THE EARLY
LEARNING NETWORK. AUSTIN'S OUR
FOCUS IN THIS CONVERSATION'S
BEEN ON EARLY MATH. AND THIS NEW
POLICY RECOMMENDATION IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE THEY ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
RESIDENTS.
.
THERE WERE IN TWO THOUSAND LEVIN
TWELVE LABOR NO PRESCHOOLS.
NO PRESCHOOL.
AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THERE'RE A HUNDRED AND
NINETY SLOTS NOW FOR PRESCHOOL.
WHATEVER OUTCOMES IS NOT JUST
ANY OLD PRESCHOOL WE'RE TALKING
QUALITY PRESCHOOLS IT'S NOT A
PLACE TO HOUSE CHILDREN. IS THE
PLACE TO HELP CHILDREN GROW.
AND DEVELOP.
AND THE CHILDREN ENTER
KINDERGARTEN READY TO SUCCEED SO
IT'S NOT JUST HOUSING THEM IT IS
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN THEY ARE
THERE. THEY LEARN AND ARE
PREPARED TO SUCCEED IN
KINDERGARTEN SO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SCORES. THESE PERCENTAGES.
THEY ARE MEASURED BY THE D. RDP
WHICH IS ACTUALLY AN ASSESSMENT
PUT TOGETHER BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. AND THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD.
COALITION.
AND THE D. RDP HAS TOLD US THAT
IN KINDERGARTEN WHEN THE
CHILDREN FIRST GET THERE FROM
MORE HERE PROMISE TO BIRDS
PRESCHOOLS.
NINETY TWO PERCENT OF THEM ARE
READY TO ENTER KINDERGARTEN TO
SUCCEED IN MATHEMATICS.
IN SCIENCE EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT
OF THEM ARE READY TO SUCCEED.
AND LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT EMERGES
OUT OF GOOD HANDS ON QUALITY
ACTIVITIES.
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT NINETY
THREE PERCENT AND LITERACY
DEVELOPMENT NINETY TWO PERCENT.
YOU KNOW FIGURE SOMETHING KID
SOMETHING INTERESTING TO ENGAGE
IN THE GOING TO TALK ABOUT NEWS
LANGUAGE IN POWERFUL WAYS SORT
MID SENSIBLE IF YOU HAVE HANDS
ON MATH AND STEM ACTIVITIES.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK.
IN FACILITATED TEACHER TALK.
I THINK ALSO IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I'LL JUST.
THERE'S LOTS MORE THERE.
BUT I THINK I'LL JUST MOVE TO
THE NEXT NETWORK JUST BRIEFLY
AND HIGHLIGHT.
HIGH SCHOOL.
TRANSITION FROM MIDDLE SCHOOL
TO HIGH SCHOOL CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM.
IN LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
OFTEN A PROBLEM IF YOU LOOK AT
THE THE ABSENTEEISM RATE. AND
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM MOVED FROM.
BY TWENTY FOUR PERCENT DECREASED
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM DURING THAT
TIME FRAME.
AND CESAR CHAVEZ THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHRONIC AS ANTI ISM
FOR.
ABS AFRICAN STUDENTS DROPPED
FROM THIRTY FIVE PERCENT CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM THE THIRTY THEIR
POPULATION.
WERE CHRONICALLY ABSENT DROP TO
SIXTEEN PERCENT.
OKAY UP FOR MALE ABSENTEEISM
DROPPED TO EIGHT PERCENT
EIGHTEEN PERCENT.
THESE ARE BIG NUMBERS.
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THEY'VE INCREASED
ARE NOT ENOUGH WERE STILL IN THE
BEGINNING BUT THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE INCREASED YOU SEE IT ON THE
CHART THERE.
HERE'S SOMETHING REALLY
IMPORTANT I WANTED TO JUST PUT A
POST SECONDARY DEGREE EVERYONE
HAS SAID IN THE LITERATURE
COURSE AND THEN THE COMPANY
SAYING WE NEED MORE POSTED POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES.
TENNYSON HIGHS.
POST SECONDARY ACTIVITY IN A
TEST OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES.
INCREASED BY EIGHTY NINE PERCENT
SHOWBOAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
FIVE YEARS THAT'S A REMARKABLE
FIGURE. THEY DIDN'T THINK THEY
COULD DO THIS.
BUT CREATING THE SMOOTH
TRANSITION PATHWAYS MAKE SHOW
THEM IT'S POSSIBLE.
AND I THINK I NEED TO CLOSE TO.
I'M DONE THERE'S MORE GO AHEAD
AND TAKE A LOOK AT HEALTH
EMPOWERMENT THIS IS A TO THE ONE
PART PART ABOUT THIS IS A TO
GENERATION APPROACH. YOU WE ARE
JUST WORKING WITH THE KIDS ARE
WORKING WITH THE FAMILIES AND
YOU'LL SEE ON THAT LAST NETWORK
THAT HOW MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TECHNICAL EDUCATION THE PARENTS
OF ALSO HAD SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPEN FOR QUESTIONS
AFTERWARDS.
THAT TO NELSON SAYS ON GUNS WE
CALL DROP IN THE MIKE.
I COULD SEE ON YOUR FACE AND I'M
GLAD. AND.
IT'S A THANK YOU FOR THE LEVEL
OF OWNERSHIP. NOW WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT BEING THE PRINCIPAL
RESEARCHER OF FOR THE HEREBY
PROMISE UNLESS SOME OF HER TO
DEAN. A SAY THAT KIND OF THING
AND FOR TALKING ABOUT RESULTS
BASS ACCOUNTABILITY HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT ANYBODY IS BETTER OFF
CAN WE PROVE IT.
WILL HAVE QUESTIONS IN JUST A
FEW MOMENTS AT THAT THANK YOU
AND WE LOVE TO HEAR FROM OUR
MISCONDUCT.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. I'M HERE
TODAY TO COULD TO BRIEFLY
DISCUSS THE NEEDS OF THE STATE
RELATED TO.
TEACHER DEVELOPMENT AND STUDENT
LEARNING AND HIGHLIGHT SEVERAL
MODELS A COLLABORATION THAT ARE.
SUPPORTING STEM DEVELOPMENT AND
OUR REGION AS YOUR PUPPY WHEREIN
TWENTY THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA
ADOPTED NEW SCIENCE STANDARDS
NEXT GENERATION SCIENCE
STANDARDS ARE FOUNDATIONAL. TO.
TO ENSURING THAT ALL STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO A ROBUST HIGH
QUALITY SITES EDUCATION STARTING
IN THE EARLY SERVE GRADES.
THE GOAL OF THE STANDARDS IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE WELL
INFORMED CITIZENS TO PREPARE FOR
COLLEGE AND CAREERS AND
UNDERSTAND APPRECIATE THE
SCIENTIFIC ENTERPRISE. THAT'S
HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN THE CASE
IN OUR SCIENCE STANDARDS AND THE
PASTOR ST SCANNERS BEEN TAUGHT
AS A BODY OF KNOWLEDGE FOR
STUDENTS TO MASTER. AND THEN TO
BE ABLE TO TRANSLATE THAT
MASTERY OF CONTENT BACK IN A WAY
THAT'S BEEN PRESCRIBED IT WITH
THE ONE ANSWER ONLY APPROACH.
THE INJUSTICE CALLS FOR
REFOCUSING QUE TWELVE SIGNS FOR
IMPROVED COLLEGE PREPARATION
STEM CAREER READINESS. AND
ABILITY OF ALL MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS.
TO ACCOMPLISH AS THE INJUSTICE
FOCUSES ON DEVELOPING THE
HABITANTS
SKILLS THAT SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS USE IN THEIR DATED A
LIFE.
STUDENTS WILL SHIP FROM LEARNING
ABOUT SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING TO
FIGURE IT OUT AND MAKING SENSE
OF PHENOMENA AND LOCAL PROBLEMS.
THIS DEEPER FOCUS ON
UNDERSTANDING AND APPLICATION
REQUIRE NEW APPROACHES TO
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR
TEACHERS AND A RECOGNITION THAT
BECOMING AN EFFECTIVE SCIENCE
TEACHER OR STEM TEACHER IS A
CONTINUOUS PROCESS THAT.
STRETCHES FROM PRE SERVICE
EXPERIENCES AN UNDERGRADUATE
YEARS TO END OF A PROFESSIONAL
CAREER.
I LIKE HIGHLIGHTS SEVERAL KEY
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FEATURES
THAT WILL BE NEEDED TO REALIZE.
STEM QUA HIGH QUALITY STEM
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS.
AND TEACHERS.
ONE WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
TEACHERS ARE GOING TO MAKES
NEED TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT SHIFTS
IN THE WAY THAT CONTENT AND THE
MATTER THAT THEY DELIVER CONTENT
IN THEIR CLASSROOMS IF STUDENTS
ARE TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN
THESE TO.
NEW SET OF STANDARDS.
AND THAT SHIFT IT'S GOING TO
HELP THEM REQUIRE THEM TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT HOW THEY LEARN
SCIENCE ESPECIALLY IN THEIR
UNDERGRADUATE YEARS. TYPICALLY.
WE NEED TO DESIGN PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES. THAT
ALLOW TEACHERS TO GRAPPLE WITH
BOTH THE SCIENCE OR STEM CONTENT
AS WELL AS TO THINK ABOUT HOW
STUDENTS THINK AND LEARN ABOUT
THE CONTENT AREA.
WE NEED TO ALSO A PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING THAT I INTRODUCES NEW
INSTRUCTIONAL APPROACHES THAT'S
GROUNDED IN THE CONTEXT OF THAT
CONTENT WHETHER IT'S SCIENCE OR
ENGINEERING AMOUNT.
NOT HAVE THOSE AYE INSTRUCTIONAL
STRATEGIES BE DELIVERED IN
ISOLATION IT'S REALLY HARD FOR
TEACHERS TO MASTER THAT AND
THINK ABOUT WHAT IS THAT MEAN
AND THE CONTENT.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR
STUDENTS.
LEARNING EXPERIENCES FOR
TEACHERS TO BE CLOBBERED IN
SUPPORT TEACHERS AND WORKING
TOGETHER TO UNDERSTAND APPLY AND
REFLECT ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF.
R. SCIENCE STANDARDS AS WELL AS
OUR UP AND COMING NEW COMPUTER
SCIENCE STANDARDS.
WE ALSO NEED TO RECOGNIZE A ONE
SIZE FITS DOZEN BURKE.
TEACHERS ARE UNIQUE ON THE HAVE
UNIQUE NEEDS AND TEACHERS IN
ELEMENTARY MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL HAVE. VERY UNIQUE NEEDS.
.
AS WE BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING IT ALSO
NEEDS TO BE DESIGNED AS PART OF
A COHERENT SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
AND FINALLY IN THINKING ABOUT.
SINCE RECORDS TALK THAT EARLY
MATH INITIATIVE AN EARLY
SCIENCES I LIKE TO THINK ABOUT
IT.
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW THIS
IS GOING TO START IN THE EARLY
SAID GRADES.
AND OUR ELEMENTARY STUDENTS ARE
GIVEN INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LITERACY
DEVELOPMENT.
THEN COMES ELT AND MOUTH. AND
OCCASIONALLY SCIENCE AND A
RECENT STUDY THAT WE DID ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE SERVER DISTRICTS
ANNUALLY. AND QUE TO TEACHERS
ARE.
ABLE TO PROVIDE ON AVERAGE
THIRTY MINUTES OF SCIENCE
INSTRUCTION WEEKLY IF IT'S
OCCURRING AT ALL. AND UP TO
FORTY FIVE MINUTES IF IT'S IN
THE THREE THREE FIVE.
WE SEE A HIGHER NUMBER MINUTES
OF COURSE IN FOURTH AND FIFTH
GRADE BECAUSE HISTORICALLY
THAT'S WHAT OUR SCIENCE
ASSESSMENT HAS TESTED.
TEACHERS REPORT THAT THERE ARE
NOT PERMITTED AT TIMES TO TEACH
SCIENCE THAT THEY NEED TO FOCUS
ON THE LITERACY. BUSINESS OUT OF
SCIENCE STANDARDS ARGUE THAT WE
DEVELOP LITERATE STUDENTS
THROUGH THE CONTEXT OF SCIENCE
MATH APPLICATION. AS CAROLYN
MENTIONED ARE CAN ALSO MENTIONED
THAT IS THE GREAT WAY FOR
LITERACY TO DEVELOP.
FOR OUR SCHOOLS BOTH THE NUMBER
AND AGREE A CHANGES REQUIRED TO
IMPLEMENT THESE NEW STANDARDS IS
GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANT.
A CONSIDERABLE PREPARATION TIME
IS NEEDED BEFORE AND AFTER
FORMALLY ADOPTION FOR BOTH SIDES
EDUCATOR IN SCHOOL LEADERS
UNDERSTAND THE SHIPS TO
PARTICIPATE IN PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING.
PILOT WORK CONTINUES SHE CHANGES
MOST DISTRICTS RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY NEED PARTNERS
TO INITIATE AND SUSTAIN THIS
WORK.
MANY PROGRAMS AND STRUCTURES IN
THE STATE STRUGGLE WITH
INCONSISTENT FUNDING THOUGH. ON
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE AWARE THAT
OUR CALIFORNIA MATH SCIENCE
PARTNERSHIP GRANT THAT REALLY
FUNDED AND SUSTAINED A LOT OF
WORK ACROSS THE STATE.
OR NONEXISTENT THIS COMING YEAR
AND SO THE EXPERTISE AND THE
STRUCTURES THAT EXISTED THERE
HAVE GONE AWAY AND DISTRICTS ARE
LEFT GRAPPLING WITH THESE.
THESE VERY COMPLEX SET OF NEW
STANDARDS.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT ONE MODEL
THOUGH THAT'S BEEN SUPPORTING
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NEEDS US
HAS A GREAT SUCCESS.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER.
I'M AT ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE
SAID BUT I'M ALSO A CAL STATE
EAST BAY IS ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE PROJECT
DIRECTORS. AND IT'S SUCH A
PRIVILEGE PLACE TO BE ABLE TO BE
A PARTNER BETWEEN ON A
UNIVERSITY IN A COUNTY OFFICE
ADD AS WE GET.
LEVERAGE THE EXPERTISE OF OUR
SCIENCE FACULTY ARE EDUCATION
FACULTY AND THEN THE
PRACTITIONER EXPERTISE THAT AND
THE STEM.
AT THE COUNTY OFFICE.
WORKING COLLECTIVELY TOGETHER WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WRITE.
FOR FUNDING AND.
DESIGN AND DELIVER HIGH QUALITY.
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THROUGH
GRANT.
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST FUNDING.
WAS INTERPRETED MIDDLE SCHOOL
SCIENCE FOTOS AND US HAVE FUNDED
WAS TARGETING STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS THAT ARE OF
HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDERREPRESENTED IN STEM. AND
ELEVEN OF OUR DISTRICTS IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. THE
RESULTS FROM THAT.
WORK I'VE BEEN PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL RECEIVED ON TEACHER
AND STUDENT CONTENT GAINES AS
MEASURED ON PRE AND POST.
WE SEE THAT TEACHERS ARE UP
TAKING NEW INSTRUCTIONAL
PRACTICES AND STUDENTS ARE
REPORTING.
A GREATER.
IDENTITY OF SCIENCE AND MORE
EFFICACY.
WE ALSO SEE A SHIFT IN AND AND
FACULTY PRACTICES AS OUR
FACULTIES ENGAGE IN THIS
COMMITTEE OF PRACTICE WITH
TEACHERS. AND WITH ON THE
PETITIONS THAT THE COUNTY OFFICE
THEY BEGIN TO THINK AND REFLECT
ABOUT WHAT THEIR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS NEEDS IN ORDER TO
LEARN.
A NEW.
GRANT.
THAT WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO
USE WE HUNDREDS SESSION FROM
HIGH SCHOOL AND MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND ELEMENTARY RECOGNIZING THAT
THAT WAS THE GREATER NEED AND SO
WE HAD CALIFORNIA MUST P. WHICH
WAS FOCUSING ON TEACHERS IN
GRADES THREE THROUGH FIVE.
AND MEASURED BY THE EXTERNAL
EVALUATION BECAUSE OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT MODEL
WE HAD THE SECOND HIGHEST COURT
OF CONTENT CANYON FOR TEACHERS
AND NEW PRACTICES ACROSS THE
STATE. IN JUST TWO YEARS WHAT'S
UNIQUE ABOUT THIS PROFESSIONAL
DEFAULT MODEL IS IS NOT JUST
CONTENT DELIVERY FOR TEACHERS.
IT'S CONTENT WITH NEW
INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICES THAT
SUPPORT THE CONTENT.
WITH INTENSIVE FOLLOW UP DURING
THE ACADEMIC YEAR WERE TEACHERS
ENGAGE IN LESSON STUDY WHICH IS
A CYCLE OF INQUIRY.
AND ADMINISTRATIVE DEVELOPMENT.
WE BRING TOGETHER LEADERS AT THE
DISTRICT INSIGHT LEVEL WITH
THESE TEACHER LEADERS THINK
ABOUT TRANSFORMATIONAL PRACTICES
THAT ARE REALLY GOING TO MAKE
DIFFERENCES IN THE WAY THAT
SCIENCE HAS TALKED.
ON.
THERE'S ANOTHER.
PROGRAM THAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
COUNTY OFFICE AND I'D LIKE TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT AND ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES IS COMPATIBLE BUT
MORE IN DETAIL.
AND THAT'S THE ALIGNMENT BAY
AREA THE ALIGNMENT VERY SICK
CLOBBERED OF IMPACT INITIATIVE
BRINGING TOGETHER LEADERS OF
EDUCATION INDUSTRY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PORTS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. THAT LEAD
YOU THROUGH COLLEGE TO CAREERS
TO INTEGRATE AND TRANSFORM
SYSTEMS THIS MODEL BEGAN WITH
THE CREW TRUST PATHWAY WORK.
AND WAS EXPANDED WITH IBM
INTERCEPT RANDOM WHICH OF THE
INCLUDES GRANT.
AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A HAND
OUT YOUR PACKET AND THAT GRANTS
ARE CALLED.
RECESS OR REGIONAL
COLLABORATION TO EXPAND AND
STRENGTHEN STEM.
THE LYMAN BAY AREA JOINS BOTH OF
THESE EFFORTS TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE REGIONAL FOCUS THREE
NETWORKS PARTNERSHIPS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. I POINT THAT OUT
BECAUSE THIS IS AGAIN ANOTHER
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN A COUNTY OFFICE AND
UCSF.
AND A CALIFORNIA SCIENCE PROJECT
SITE.
BOTH OF THESE MODELS ANY POLICY
IN FUNDING TO CONTINUE SUPPORT.
EARLY ENTRANT ENTRY AND
PIPELINE STEM CAREERS IN IMPORTS
CITIZENS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CONNOR WHO KNEW
THIS TURNED INTO A CAL STATE
EAST BAY OUT PANEL.
.
YOU KNOW CHINA I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER CAL STATE
EAST BAY YOU WEAR A LOT OF HATS
IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER STUFF.
AND IT TENDS. Y. HELL LIVE YOU
HAVE.
A FULL DISCLOSURE OF PIN A
LECTURER CAL STATE HE SPEAK ALSO
WHO KNEW. THAT STEM A CALLOUSED
EIGHTY SPAY WAS THE CONVERSATION
THAT I POINT OUT ONE THING
PLEASE AND CAL CD SPIN A WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT WE
DO IN THIS FIELD. BUT WE'RE NOT
THE ONLY ONES AND.
FRANKLY I'VE JUST BEEN THERE
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF OR
SO BUT I'VE BEEN SO AMAZED AT
WHAT DOES GO ON IN TEACHING
TEACHERS HOW TO TEACH.
STAND TO HURT DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND SORT OF THE
WHOLE GAMUT AND OUT OF SCHOOL
TIME AND EVERYTHING. BUT THE CAL
STATE SYSTEM IS.
THE PRESIDENT AND I WENT TO A
MEETING LAST YEAR THAT THE
CHANCELLOR CALLED.
STATEWIDE TO TALK ABOUT THIS
WORK A LOT OF THE CSU CAMPUSES
ARE DOING REALLY INNOVATIVE
VALUABLE WORK IN THIS VERY
FIELD.
SO TO AND THEN.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS YOU
KNOW SHORT CHANGING BUTTON
EVERYBODY BUT.
DIDN'T TAKE ANYWAY SUPPORTING
RECOGNIZING THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM PARTICULARLY
FURTHER VALUE IN TRAINING
TEACHERS.
WOULD BE AN ENORMOUS STRUCTURAL
IMPROVEMENT IN EDUCATION IN ALL
FIELDS BUT PARTICULARLY STEM.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD JUST
MAKE WHENEVER THEY WANTED TO.
I THINK THAT'S AN ACCURATE IN
RIGHTEOUS SHAMELESS PLUG UP AND
RIGHT ON TIME THAT. IT'S TRUE.
WE HAVE GREAT INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING THAT NEED
INVESTMENT.
IN IN THE CSU SYSTEM. AYE IN
THE UC SYSTEM AND I COMMITTEE
COSTUMES ARE ALL FANTASTIC. ARE
CLEARLY TODAY'S PANEL IS A A
TESTAMENT TO CAL STATE EAST BAY
AND WHAT THAT INVESTMENT HAS
BEEN MEANT. AND I SURE HOPE THAT
THE ENROLLMENT JUST SHOT UP IN
THIS WAS A GREAT COMMERCIAL CAO
YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU ALL DO
I'M I WANT YOU THE QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
.
TERROR SAW CHAU SPEAKING OF CAL
STATE EAST BAY.
I'M JUST WONDERING.
IF THERE IS ARE YOU UNDER
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN IN STEM
AT THE ACCOUNTS THAT YOU SPACE.
BECAUSE HISTORICALLY WOMEN HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN ON THE REPRESENTED
IN COMPUTER SCIENCE THEM WHAT'S
UP STEAM AYE EDUCATION SO AND IF
SO ARE WAY DOWN HOW DO WE
RECTIFY THAT SITUATION. OF FOR
FOR YOU FOLKS OUT YOU KNOW AND
ALSO FORECASTING IN GENERAL AND
AND ALSO THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
I THINK YOU SHOULD.
ALRIGHT WE'RE VERY DIVERSE WE
HAVE ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT WOMEN
IN IN THE UNIVERSITY AND WE HAVE
GOOD REPRESENTATION IN THE
SCIENCES WE ARE HIRING WOMEN
INTO THE FIELDS WE. IN OUR
PHYSICS DEPARTMENT THE LAST
THREE HOW FOR HIRES THREE HAVE
BEEN WOMEN TO MINORITIES AND SO
WE'RE REALLY WORKING VERY HARD
IN TERMS OF DIVERSIFYING OUR
FACULTY. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY CAN REPRESENT.
THE FACES OF OUR STUDENTS AS
WELL AND THEN TO REALLY WORK
TOWARDS THEIR GRADUATION AND SO
WE'RE DOING A LOT OF EFFORTS IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO. ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE INTO THE FIELDS.
SO WE'RE STARTING AT THE SCHOOLS
RIGHT AND TEACHING THEM IN
THROUGH. THE SCIENCE DAYS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT BAYER AND
OTHERS HAVE HELP TO SUPPORT WE
ARE GETTING MORE PEOPLE
INTERESTED IN THE FIELDS AND
LEARN EATEN THEM KNOWING ABOUT
IT. SO IT'S REALLY BUILDING THAT
PIPELINE IN THERE ONCE THEY'RE
WITH US TRIED PROVIDE SERVICES
SUCCEED.
THANK YOU.
LIQUIDATED CLAD ONES ONTO IT
YEAH ONE OF THE THINGS TO LEARN
THAT WE THINK BROADLY ABOUT IS
HOW DO WE ENCOURAGE AN IDENTITY
AS A SCIENCE CAPABLE PERSON.
MULLIN TALK WITH EDUCATORS OFTEN
WILL SEE THESE AMAZING STUDENTS
BOTH MALE AND FEMALES THAT COME
THERE ARE CLASS.
RARELY DO WE RECOGNIZE AND SAY
THAT YOU MAKE A GREAT EDUCATOR A
SCIENCE EDUCATOR WILL SAY THAT
YOU'LL MAKE A GREAT SCIENTISTS
MIGHT MAKE A GREAT ENGINEER.
I THINK THAT IS TEACHERS
DEVELOPMENT THEIR IDENTITIES
SPECIAL OUR ELEMENTARY WHICH HAS
TEACHERS.
AS THEIR IDENTITY IS SCIENCE
CAPABLE AND THAT THEY CREATE
ROBUST LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS AND THEN ME AND
FEMALE STUDENTS IN THOSE GRADES
FEEL LIKE THEY BELONG IN THOSE
COURSES AND SUPPORTED. IN
ENGAGING AND SINCE MAKING AND
THAT THEIR IDEAS COUNT THEM WE
WILL SEE MORE STUDENTS INTO
READING COLLEGE PREPARED AND
FEEL LIKE THAT'S A PLACE TO
BELONG.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE STARTED
WITH ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
MATH AND EARLY LEARNING AND MATH
LITERACY AND MISS OFFENDER WHEN
YOU TALKED ABOUT MATH FUN I HAVE
TO ADMIT.
I HAD FLASHBACKS
TO SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH MY
YOUNGEST THAT. I THINK GRUELING
MIGHT BE AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
AND THAT'S JUST ME A LOT OF
CRYING.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
TO HER MATH PACKET CLOWN CAN THE
YOU TALKED ABOUT MATH LITERACY.
A KINDERGARTEN.
IT INTO THAT MEAN BY.
TIME THE STUDENT STARTS
KINDERGARTEN OR BY THE TIME
THEY'VE COMPLETED CAN THE
GARDEN.
AND WHAT COMPONENTS ARE REALLY
ADVOCATING I KNOW THAT SO MUCH
OF LITERATURE TALKS ABOUT.
.
OR LITERACY IN GENERAL AND USING
KINDERGARTEN IS A TIME TO REALLY
SOCIALIZE STUDENTS TO SCHOOL AND
NOT OVERWHELMING THEM. OR
INTIMIDATING THEM WHAT ARE WE
ASKING.
OUR STUDENTS TO KNOW AND LEARN.
BY KINDERGARTEN AS RELATES TO
MATHEMATICS.
BECAUSE SOME OF MY CONTENT
EXPERTS TO BACK ME UP ON THIS.
IT'S EASIER THAN I THOUGHT
BEFORE I STARTED UNDERSTANDING
THE STUFF I IT'S NOT.
PRE ALGEBRA BY AGE THREE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL MATH YEAR
INTELLECTUAL CONCEPTS THAT COME
WITH MATH THINGS LIKE GROUPING.
AND. PARA RANCIC'S EDUCATION WHO
HAVE TIES SUBITO ICING.
ANYBODY KNOW IT SUMA TYSON MEANS
ZERO.
YOU ARE.
PLAYING A BOARD GAME.
YOU LOOK AT.
THAT DIETING
ROLL
FIGURE OUT HOW MANY
SPEAKING.
THAT ACTUALLY.
DIE.
THERE ARE.
SO THERE SYMPATHETIC.
KIDS CAN LEARN THROUGH
EXPERIENCES.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THERE
SIMPLY.
HAVING A.
THEY'RE NOT HAPPY
BENEFITS
COUNTING THEIR NOT HAVING
EXPERIENCES
PLAYING GAMES THEY'RE NOT HAVING
USED.
WITH OUR GROUP BEING AND HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH ADULTS
IN THEIR LIVES THAT ALLOW THEM
TO.
SO SAY POINTING OUT OF THE BLUE
THINGS IN HER ROOM OR A LOT OF
LITTLE KIDSTHEY CAN COUNT TO
THREE. AND THEN THERE'S
SOMETHING HARD ABOUT FOUR AND
HARD ABOUT GETTING INTO YOUR ARE
THE TO YOUR OTHER HAND AND
LEARNING SIX THIS IS THAT YOU
KNOW VERY YOUNG AGES. SO IF
PARENTS ARE KIND OF AWARE OF HIS
STUFF IT'S VERY EASY TO DO AND
THEN THE STUDENTS YOU KNOW THEN
THEY CAN GROUP AND PATTERN AND
DO ALL THAT STUFF. THAT BUILDS
LATER WHEN THEY WHEN THEY GO AND
SUMA TIES. SYMPATHIZING.
IT'S GOING ON MY FACEBOOK RIGHT
NOW.
HOW HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
SYMPATHIZE?
AFTER WAS INTERPRETED YEAH YEAH
I UNDERSTOOD THAT WE COULD DO
THAT BUT NO UNTIL I HEARD YOU
DESCRIBE IT I'VE NEVER HEARD THE
PHRASE.
I GUESS MY QUESTION RELATES TO
THE LAST THING THAT YOU SAID
THAT PARENTS WHEN THEY KNOW. HOW
DO WE PACKAGE THIS IN WAYS THAT
PARENTS CAN SUE THE TIES WITH
THEIR KIDS THAT THEY CAN DO
GROUPING? IN WAYS THAT DON'T AN
INTIMIDATE THEM OR CALL ON THEIR
OWN EXPERIENCES IT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN NEGATIVE.
ALLEGEDLY YEAH.
HOW DO WE HELP PARENTS TO DO
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY?
I SHOULD HAVE BROUGHT TODAY AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO SEND THAT WE'VE
DONE A FLYER DATES IN THREE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES ENCOURAGING
PARENTS TO DO THAT. AND IT'S
INTENDED IT HAS IT'S STILL IN
ITS EARLY STAGES BUT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ALLIANCE AYE. IT'S
TO BE DISTRIBUTED AT PEDIATRICS
OFFICES AND PRESCHOOLS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT TO SHOW HOW
SIMPLE AND FIND IT CAN BE AND
THEN TO LINK TO RESOURCES THAT
YOU CAN GO ON AND YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE A MORE.
SIRIUS IS APPARENT BUT IT'S TOO
AND IT'S TO.
THERE'S AN ELEMENT OF THE PLAN
THAT INVOLVES TEACHING.
ADULTS
NOT TO BE AFRAID OF MATH ME NOT
TO RESPOND LIKE YOU AND I DO OWE
MATH GRUELING. A WITH THEIR KIDS
IT'S TO HIM IT IT IS FUN.
WE'RE DOING THAT. I.
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM CIRCLE
ARABS AND IT'S CALLED MATH
REALLY MATH GAMES
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT OUR
FACULTY AND BRUCE OF PUT
TOGETHER. TO SHOW CARE GIVERS AS
WELL AS LITTLE KIDS ARM THE FUN
STUFF.
AND I'LL JUST ADD ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT PIECES OF.
OF HELPING PARENTS SEE WHAT
THEIR CAPACITY IS IS JUST
TALKING TO THEM HAVING THEM
TAKING THEM THROUGH SOME OF
THESE MATH ACTIVITIES.
PARENTAGE EDUCATION.
IS AS IMPORTANT
AS A CHILD'S EDUCATION YOU
EDUCATE YOUR PARENTS TO EDUCATE
YOUR CHILDREN AND PROVIDE IT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM SO WE
OFFER ALMOST AS MUCH IN
PARENTING EDUCATION. IN OUR
PRESCHOOLS IN OUR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS.
ACTUALLY EVEN AT THE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL WE HAVE A PATHWAY THAT
INVOLVES PARENTS STARTING IN THE
TENTH GRADE.
WHERE AND STARTING TO BUILD A
COLLEGE CULTURE WITH THEM BUT
REALLY EARLY ON IN THE
PRESCHOOLS? THIS PARENT
EDUCATIONS ARE SUCH RICHARD
PERTINENTES TO TAKE THEM THROUGH
THE MATH GAMES.
AND I DON'T THINK WHEN WE THINK
OF EDUCATION WE DON'T TYPICALLY
THINK OF PARENT EDUCATION WHO
THINK OF IT AS  THEY HAVE A
DEGREE OR NOT ARE THEY GRADUATED
MY SCORE NOT. ITS CONTINUAL. AND
WHEN THE KIDS WHO THEIR PARENTS
LEARN AND ENJOY IT. THEY ALSO
THAT'S A MODEL FOR THE KIDS.
IT'S REALLY A MATTER OF
EMPOWERING THE PARENTS.
IN IN THE HP AND ONE OF THE PROP
PROGRAMS IS WORKING WITH THE
PARENTS TO TEACH THEM AND THAT
ADVISORY BOARD THAT CAROLYN
TALKED ABOUT. IS A PARENT
ADVISORY GROUP THAT COMES TO THE
UNIVERSITY TO MEET PAY CHOSE TO
MEET UP AT THE UNIVERSITY ON
SATURDAYS CAROLINE MEETS WITH
THEM. AND THEY WANT ONCE A MONTH
AND THEY WANT TO P. THEY'VE
TAKEN THE UNIVERSITY AS THEIR
HOME.
IT'S THEIR UNIVERSITY AND BUT IT
IS EMPOWERING THEM TO KNOW THE
QUESTIONS TO ASK IN THE THINGS
THAT THEY CAN DO AND THEY
EMBRACE IT.
LIKE YOU WERE GONNA ASK OUR
FRIENDS THE FIRST FIVE TO CHANGE
YOUR WHOLE CAMPAIGN YOU KNOW
THEY TALK ABOUT TALK READ SEEING
THAT TALK ABOUT THE BRAIN
BEHAVIOR AND HOW EARLY IT WE
MUST EXPOSE KIDS EARLY. IS GOING
TO BE TALK READ SEEING SUMA TIES
YEAH AN AD THAT WE CAN AND THAT
IS.
WE'RE GONNA FIND ANOTHER WAY TO
SAY SUMA TIES SO IT FITS
INTO THE COMMERCIAL ON HOW TO
TALK READ SAYING SUPERSIZED.
COULD YOU SAY ONE LAST WORD ON
THE AREA OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS IN THIS
CONVERSATION COMES UP A LOT.
FOR TEACHERS WHO DON'T HAVE AN
IT BACKGROUND.
HOW DO WE SUPPORT EDUCATORS ON
TO BEING GAUGED AND PREPARING
STUDENTS? FOR STAND FOR.
BEING INVOLVED IN THE
CONVERSATION EVEN WHEN THE
EDUCATORS THEMSELVES ON HAVING
IT BACK.
SO THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
SO IT COMES ON THE SUMMATION OF
COLLABORATION SO AT OUR COUNTY
OFFICE LIKE MANY COUNTY OFFICES
WE HUB INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE AN
IT ENGINEERING AND MAKER SPACE.
MENTALITY BACKGROUND AND
TRAINING AND REALLY THINKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE BREAK DOWN THE
SILOS OF EDUCATION WHERE. IT'S
MATH PERIOD AT SCIENCE PERIOD
ITS TECHNOLOGY TIME MORTON
INSTEAD HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT
THE UTILIZATION AND LEVERAGING
TECHNOLOGY. IN WAYS THAT HELP
YOU MAKE SENSE OF THE SCIENCE
THE MOUTH AND THE LITERACY. AND
AND AND UP OF THE APPLICATION OF
THAT TECHNOLOGY SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS WE'VE PARTNERED WITH
EXPERTS WHO. ARE TEACHERS WHO
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED TO WORK WITH
OTHER TEACHERS THE POWER OF
TEACHERS LEADERSHIP. AND
TRAINING OF TEACHERS IN A WAY
WHERE THEY COME IN AND THEY
LEARN THROUGH APPLICATION HANDS
ON. AND THE CREATE.
SOMETHING THAT'S RELEVANT TO
THEIR DATED A PRACTICE AS A
TEACHER THAT THEY'RE GONNA TAKE
BACK IN USE IN THE CLASSROOMS.
IS ONE OF THE BEST APPROACHIS
THAT WE HAVE FOUND BUT IT DOES
REQUIRE US TO.
MOVE AWAY FROM A SOLID APPROACH
OF.
CONTENT DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT
AROUND.
BUT WE HAVE I THINK A REALLY
GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS AND WHEN WE
WERE PUZZLING OVER HOW DO YOU
DRAW MORE FEMALES IN SCIENCE
EARLIER ON.
WE HAD SOME FACULTY OFFICE OR
SCIENCE AND SCIENCE AT FACULTY
WERE PUZZLING OVER THIS. AND WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK.
TO GET SOME SOLAR SUITCASES
IN OUR WATER PHYSICS PROFESSOR.
WAS ABLE TO GET SOME FUNDING TO
ORDER REAL SOLAR SUITCASES AND
TEACH THE CONCEPTS OF PHYSICS.
BY BUILDING THE SOLAR SUITCASES
THEY DID THIS WITH A GROUP OF
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS.
MORE THAN HALF OF THEM WERE
FEMALE.
BECAUSE THE PURPOSE WASN'T LET'S
LEARN PHYSICS LET'S LEARN
SCIENCE THAT CAN BE APPLIED IN
MEANINGFUL PURPOSEFUL WAYS.
THE STUDENTS AND THAT'S THE KEY
THEY FOUND NO WOMEN DROPPED OUT
NO YOUNG WOMAN DROPPED OUT. THEY
LOVED IT THEY THEN TOOK THE
SOLAR SUITCASES TO SOME OF OUR
PROMISE. TO OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS.
BRAVE TRYING TO PILOTED AS AN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM AGAIN HALF
THE CLASS WAS WOMEN WERE WITH
HALF OF THE CLASS NINE YEAH MORE
THAN ACTUALLY HAVE CLASS.
THERE WAS AN AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM NOT ONE STUDENT FOR SIX
WEEKS MISSED
A CLASS BECAUSE THEY WERE
BUILDING IN A HANDS ON WAY
SOMETHING INTERESTING AND
PURPOSEFUL.
IS THERE SOLIS SUITCASES WERE
GOING TO BE SHIPPED TO A COUNTRY
WHERE THEY SAW PICTURES OF THE
CHILDREN WHERE THAT WOULD BE
USING THESE IN THEIR CLASSROOMS
CROP OVERSEAS.
SO THE FACULTY NOW HAVE BUILT
THIS
APPROACH INTO THEIR THEIR
CURRICULUM.
FOR IT NEXT YEAR AT THE
UNIVERSITY LEVEL AND AGAIN
TAKING A BACK.
I THINK KEEPING THE INTEREST OF
FEMALES. ARE OF GIRLS IN SCIENCE
IT HAS TO BE HANDS ON PASTOR
PROPOSAL AND I WOULD SAY IT NOT
EVEN JUST FOR WOMEN FOR MEN TOO.
FOR YOUNG MEN.
THERE WAS A MIX OF NON SCIENCE
MAJORS
ALSO THAT ARE THE STUDENTS AT
THE UNIVERSITY WASN'T ALL
SCIENCE PAGE NEWS BUSINESS
MAJORS IT WAS PEOPLE IN THE
SOCIAL SCIENCES.
TAKING THAT CLASS AND THINKING
WELL I CAN DO THIS I CAN LEARN
ABOUT SCIENCE AND I CAN
EMPLOYER.
BUT THE OTHER PART OF IT WAS THE
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND EQUITY
COMPONENT OF IT. OF REALLY
TALKING ABOUT THAT PART IN WHAT
THE SOLICITOR EXTRA GONNA DO TO
THESE PEOPLE IN COUNTRIES THAT
DON'T HAVE ELECTRICITY AND DON'T
HAVE POWER AND DON'T HAVE
LIGHTING.
KEEP DO NOT SOLICIT CASES ARE.
THANK YOU WE.
WE WANT TO INVITE SOME OF OUR
OTHER PANELISTS TO HAVE A WORD
BUT IF YOU COULD WOULD LOVE IT
IF YOU'D STAY. I'M WE DO HAVE
SOME.
COME A FEW AT A TIME A BILL TEN
AND I SUSPECT THERE MAY BE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR ALL OF
YOU. AGAIN AT LET'S THINK OUR
FIRST PANEL.
YEAH SURE.
LOW ON.
WELL OUR NEXT PANEL COMES FOR
ALSO WHEN KNOWLEDGE.
OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA A
GREAT EDUCATOR HERSELF WE'RE
GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
WE WELCOME TO.
PRESENT.
VINCE STUART.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STAND
NETWORK.
HE'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
DARIEN LOUIS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE EAST BAY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ALLIANCE.
A DOCTOR BERT LUBIN A THE DEAN
OF PEDIATRIC HEALTH AT BENNY OFF
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. AND DOCTOR
RENEE NAVARRO.
UCSF EXECUTIVE VICE CHANCELLOR
OF DIVERSITY AND OUT REACH.
WELCOME AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR PRESENTATION.
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY WE'RE
READY PERFECT.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY.
SELECT COMMITTEE ON STEM
EDUCATION.
I'LL START BY SAYING I AM NOT
FROM CS YOU EAST BAY BUT I
CERTAINLY WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN THE
COLLEAGUES THERE.
I AM THE THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK.
AND I AM HERE TO PROVIDE A
STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE ON SOME OF
THE.
ACTIVITIES INITIATIVES AND
EFFORTS THAT ARE UNDERWAY.
WITH RESPECT STEM EDUCATION AND
WE WILL I'LL LIKELY PROCEED TO
CHANGE OUR NAME FROM STEM TO
STEAM. ALTHOUGH I KNOW DEPENDING
ON WHERE YOU ARE IN THE STATE OF
THE A COULD BE ARTSY COULD BE
AGRICULTURE SO.
THAT MIA GENERATE LITTLE THE
CONVERSATION BUT I'M SURE WE CAN
WORK IT OUT.
SO WITH RESPECT OF THE NETWORK.
WE BRING TOGETHER STAKEHOLDERS
FROM TKD TWELVE HIGHER EDUCATION
BUSINESS INDUSTRY GOVERNMENT
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
PHILANTHROPY. TO REALLY IDENTIFY
SCALE AND SO STAINED EFFECTIVE
STEM TEACHING AND LEARNING.
HOW WE WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THIRTEEN AFFILIATED REGIONAL
STEM NETWORKS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT STRETCH
FROM STRESS SHASTA COUNTY THE
SAN DIEGO AND OF COURSE THAT
INCLUDES US YES YOU EAST BAY?
THROUGH POLICY ADVOCACY
COMMUNICATIONS OUT REACH WE
STRIVE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS BUT ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN UNDERSERVED AND
UNDERREPRESENTED. IN STEM
DISCIPLINES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE HIGHEST QUALITY STEM
EDUCATION POSSIBLE.
COME I'D LIKE TO START WITH A
FEW.
IMPORTANT DATA POINTS.
JUST TO FRAME MY COMMENTS.
I THINK MOST FOLKS ARE AWARE OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF STEM OR STEAM
TO OUR ECONOMY.
SEVEN OF THE TEN FASTEST
GROWING OCCUPATIONS IN STEM
FIELDS.
SEVEN OF THE TEN EXCUSE ME
FASTEST GROWING OCCUPATIONS ARE
IN STEM FIELDS.
AND IN BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN STEM
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA GREW BY
NINETEEN PERCENT. AND I THINK
THAT GROWTH IS CERTAINLY
PROJECTED TO.
AT LEAST MAINTAINED IF NOT
INCREASE.
NOW DESPITE THESE NUMBERS OUR
SCHOOLS DON'T OFFER COURSES THAT
ARE CRITICAL FOR STEM EDUCATION
AND PREPARING FOR STEM CAREERS.
SO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR
SCHOOLS DON'T OFFER CALCULUS.
FIFTEEN PERCENT DON'T OFFER
PHYSICS
AND TEN PERCENT DON'T OFFER
CHEMISTRY.
SO. IN ADDITION THOUGH TO THIS
LIMITED ACCESS TO STEM COURSES
WE ALSO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS IN STEM
EDUCATION. THAT ARE MOST.
PRONOUNCED BY RACE AND ETHNICITY
AND THIS TRANSLATES INTO MAJOR
INEQUITIES FOR OUR STUDENTS.
THE SO THIS IS BASED ON THE
NATIONAL.
REPORT CARD SOME NAY DATA.
BUT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN
PERCENT OF AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
SEVENTEEN PERCENT OF LATINO
FOURTH GRADERS WERE PROFICIENT
IN MATH.
BY THE EIGHTH GRADE THOSE
NUMBERS DROPPED TO FOURTEEN
PERCENT AND THIRTEEN PERCENT
RESPECTIVELY.
THE NUMBERS FOR SCIENCE ARE
EQUALLY TROUBLING.
PROFICIENCY FOR OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO STUDENTS IN
GRADES FOUR AND A REMAIN STATIC
AT ABOUT ELEVEN PERCENT.
SO WE SEE THAT WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT GAP. AND
INSTEAD OF MAKING PROGRESS AS
CHILDREN PROGRESS THROUGH THEIR
ORIGINAL EDUCATIONAL CAREERS
WERE ACTUALLY MOVING.
BUT THEY ARE BACKWARD OR WERE
STAYING THE SAME.
SO FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
NETWORK THE ISSUES OF ACCESS
EQUITY AND STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
IN STEM EDUCATION HARI STATEWIDE
CONCERN. AND ONE THAT WE BELIEVE
ARE REQUIRES STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP.
HAS A STATE CALIFORNIA MUST
MAKE STEM EDUCATION A PRIORITY
AND INVEST ACCORDINGLY.
SO WHAT SHOULD WE DO.
I THINK WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF EARLY MATH
INSTRUCTION AND I WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO THE FOLKS AT
FIRST FIVE I KNOW THAT I'VE
RECENTLY SEEN SOME OF THEIR.
NEW COMMERCIALS RUNNING WHERE
IT IS BOTH TALK READ SING AND
COUNT.
WILL HAVE TO GET THEM TO MAYBE
BROADEN THAT LITTLE BIT BUT I
THINK THERE IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT.
THAT THAT MATH LITERACY IN THE
EARLY GRADES IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
WE CERTAINLY KNOW BASED ON
BRAIN RESEARCH ECONOMIC ANALYSES
THAT INVESTING IN OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN YIELDS THE MOST
POSITIVE IMMEDIATE AND LONG TERM
BENEFITS.
EXPOSURE TO HIGH QUALITY
ENGAGING MATH AND SCIENCE
INSTRUCTION IN THE EARLY YEARS
HELPS TO CREATE A MORE POSITIVE
ASSOCIATION WITH THE SUBJECTS.
AND PROMOTE GREATER STUDENT
INTEREST.
.
TRINA HAD MENTIONED I THINK.
THE.
BENEFITS OF EARLY MATH SKILLS
WE KNOW THAT COMPREHENSION. A OF
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE MATH
SKILLS AND CONCEPTS IS ACTUALLY
A STRONGER PREDICTOR OF LONGER
TERM ACADEMIC SUCCESS EVEN MORE
SO THAN LITERACY. I THINK THIS
RESEARCH COMING OUT OF UC
IRVINE.
THAT REALLY SUBSTANTIATES THIS
AS WELL AS ELSEWHERE.
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE.
MATH AND SCIENCE CURRICULUM ALSO
PROVIDES ENGLISH.
LEARNERS WITH CONCRETE
OPPORTUNITIES.
PRACTICE REFINED THEIR SPEAKING
LISTENING CRITICAL THINKING
SKILLS.
SO THE QUESTION ISN'T SO MUCH
WHETHER KIDS ARE READY TO ENGAGE
IN THE SUBJECTS HAVE AN EARLY
AGE BUT RATHER OUR COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING THE NECESSARY ACCESS
AND SUPPORTS FOR HIGH QUALITY
STEM INSTRUCTION.
THROUGHOUT T. K. BUT ESPECIALLY
THE ELEMENTARY GRADES.
AND THAT IS WHY THE CALIFORNIA
THEM EDUCATION AND INCREASED
SUPPORT FOR EDUCATORS IN STEM
SUBJECTS.
AS POLICY PRIORITIES.
A RECENT REPORT I THINK THIS IS
FROM THE.
A NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
FOUND THAT AMONG ELEMENTARY
EDUCATORS ONLY ABOUT A THIRD
REPORTED HAVING COMPLETED AT
LEAST ONE COURSE. IN THE STEM
SUBJECTS OF LIFE.
EARTH AND PHYSICAL SCIENCES
DURING THEIR EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
SO THIS IS WHY WE SUPPORT SOME
VERY SPECIFIC STEPS THAT WE
THINK WILL HELP ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF TEACHER TRAINING THE
TEACHER PIPELINE AND REALLY
BUILDING OUT A MUCH MORE ROBUST.
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SERVE MORE TO
SUPPORT STEM TEACHING AND
LEARNING.
SO FIRST
A PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
STEM TEACHERS PRINCIPALS AND
SCHOOL LEADERS IN THE ELEMENTARY
GRADES.
WE NEED TO EXPAND THE PIPELINE
OF NEW STEM TEACHERS BY FUNDING
MORE TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
I'M I THINK THIS IS A POINT THAT
CAME UP EARLIER IN TERMS OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT THE CSU CERTAINLY
AT THE FOREFRONT WEEDS I'VE BEEN
TALKING WITH FOLKS FROM CAMPUSES
IN THE. CSU CHANCES OFFICE AS TO
HOW WE CAN REALLY DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THOSE EFFORTS.
WE NEED TO FUND INCENTIVES TO
ATTRACT NEW AND RETAIN EXISTING
TEACHERS TO MAKE THIS PROFESSION
APPEALING AND TO COMPETE QUITE
HONESTLY FOR THE BEST AND THE
BRIGHTEST FOR BEING LURED AWAY.
BY CAREERS IN IN TACK AND AND
WE KNOW THAT THE DISPARITIES
THERE IN TERMS OF OF THE
ECONOMIC REWARDS BUT THERE ARE
OTHER REWARDS. IN TERMS OF
COMING INTO THE TEACHING
PROFESSION THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO TALK UP.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE GREATER
ACCESS TO STEM INSTRUCTION FOR
STUDENTS IN RURAL SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
GREAT DISPARITY IN TERMS OF.
THEIR ABILITY TO ACCESS THAT
INSTRUCTION IN THAT RANGES
EVERYTHING FROM.
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE TO THE
ACCESS OF.
AP COURSES AND A WHOLE HOST OF
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE THINK WE
NEED TO ADDRESS.
WE WANNA SEE AN INCREASED
FUNDING FOR COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION IN TERMS OF STEM
PROFESSIONS WE KNOW THAT.
THE GROWTH.
WITHIN JOBS THAT REQUIRE
COMPUTER SCIENCE TRAINING OR
DEGREES.
IS AT LEAST FIFTY PERCENT IF
NOT MORE OVER THE NEXT.
SEVERAL YEARS.
WE ALSO WANT TO SEE A STUDY OF
THE AMOUNT OF INSTRUCTIONAL TIME
IT'S BEING SPENT ON MATH AND
SCIENCE.
SO WE CAN WORK TO BALANCE THAT
OUT SO THAT STUDENTS DO GET THE
SKILLS THEY NEED FROM A VERY
EARLY AGE WITHIN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL CAREER. TO BECOME
MORE PROFICIENT AND.
DO WELL ACADEMICALLY AS THEY
MOVE FORWARD.
ALL OF THESE ITEMS ARE DRESSED.
OR WILL BE ADDRESSED IN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
SIX.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN.
THE CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK IS
PLEASED TO BE A SPONSOR OF THAT
LEGISLATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT WE CAN I COUNT ON THE
SUPPORT OF OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE THAT
FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS AND JUST THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH FOR THE TIME AND
ATTENTION THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU AND I'M GLAD WE GOT A
BILL RIGHT.
WE ARE ASKING FOR A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT.
TO SUPPORT EXPANDING COMPUTER
SCIENCE
AND MORE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ARE AROUND STEM AND
A FOCUS. ON RURAL.
AREAS THAT HAVE NOT HAD ACCESS
THANK YOU SO MUCH OBSERVE STUART
I WENT OVER TO OUR COLLEAGUES ON
THE DEMOCRAT SILVA FOR FEW
REMARKS.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY AND NINE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON THIS
COMMITTEE. I DO HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AND THEN A FEW
QUESTIONS AND AS I CAME IN LATE
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR ALL OF
THE PRESENTATION BUT THERE WERE
A FEW THINGS THAT JUMPED OUT AT
ME.
I'VE BEEN A A. B. ELEMENTARY
TEACHER FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS
AND I.
I JUST WANNA SEE WHO'S IN THE
AUDIENCE DO WE HAVE ANY
PRINCIPLES OUT THERE. IN THE
AUDIENCE.
ANY TRUSTEES PART OF TRUSTEES.
A ANY SUPERINTENDENTS.
OKAY IT'S GOING THROUGH. SO
FIRST EARNED IN AGAIN I'M JUST
I'M I'M GONNA TRY NOT TO TAKE
TOO MUCH TIME HERE BUT.
.
IN THIRTY YEARS YOU SEE SWINGS
FROM.
WAY BACK IN THE EIGHTIES WHEN I
STARTED TEACHING THAT WE DID
MATH THEIR WAY I DON'T DOES
ANYBODY REMEMBER MATH THEIR WAY.
SO WE HAVE A FEW PEOPLE MATH
THEIR WAY WAS ACTUALLY EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
THAT FOCUSED ON HANDS ON MATH.
WHERE KIDS WERE COUNTING
TOUCHING MEASURING ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE HUGE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT AND KIT SIN? AND ALL
OF THESE THINGS TEACHERS SPEND
THEIR WEEKENDS COLORING LITTLE.
BEINGS MAKING FACES ON I'M
COLLECTING THINGS ON THE WHOLE
EMPHASIS WAS THINGS LIKE MAKING
PATTERNS SO EVENTUALLY WHEN THEY
GOT OLDER.
THEN THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND SOME
OF THESE.
KIND OF PATTERNS YOU SEE AND
HIGHER ED IN MATH AND. THEN WE
WENT ALL THE WAY BACK TO
EVERYTHING WAS KIND OF PAPER
PENCIL AND VERY RIGOR AND WE'RE
NOT DOING THIS PLANE
DEVELOPMENTAL STUFF AND THEN WE
CUT IT. BACK THE OTHER WAY AND
BY NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK THE
OTHER WAY SO.
WHEN I HEAR ABOUT THINGS LIKE
TEACHER TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DIE IN A. AYE AYE I
DO WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE
TEACHERS BECAUSE EVEN SOMETHING
THAT YOU JUST SAID ABOUT LIKE
HOW MUCH TIME IS SOMEBODY REALLY
SPENDING ON MATH OR SCIENCE IN
THEIR CLASS.
I WOULD ASK ALL OF YOU TO DO THE
MATH EQUATION OF HOW MANY
MINUTES ARE MANDATED FOR EACH
SUBJECT AND THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NO WAY THAT TEACHERS CAN DO
EVERY SINGLE THING. THAT IS
REQUIRED EVEN BY THE STATE FOR
CURRICULUM WHETHER BP. UP P. E.
HERE ARE ACTOR ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
DONE AYE AND DO YOU KNOW A HUGE
INVESTMENT AS YOU'RE SAYING. NOW
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN TEACHERS
DID QUITE A BIT OF THEMATIC
TEACHING THAT ALLOW THEM TO
MAYBE PULL IN SOME LITERATURE
LITERACY AND THINGS THAT MIGHT
MAYBE THEY WERE DOING MATH ALONG
WITH THAT. BUT THE THE OVERALL
ARCHING THING IS WE WANT THIS
CURRICULUM YOU KNOW IT'S GOOD WE
KNOW IT'S GOOD THE KIDS KNOW
IT'S GOOD YOU SEE AN ENGAGEMENT
YOU SEE A RESPONSE BUT THEN THE
WHOLE OTHER SIDE OF THE STORY.
IS AND THAT'S WHY I ASKED ABOUT
PRINCIPLES ADMINISTRATORS AND
TRUSTEES THEY WANT HIGH TEST
SCORES.
AND EVEN THOUGH THEY SAY THEY
WANT ENRICHED CLASSROOMS AND
THEY WANT EVERYBODY GOING FROM
GROUP TO GROUP BUT COLLABORATIVE
THINKING AND ALL OF THESE
THINGS.
BOTTOM LINE IS THEY WANT.
HIGH TEST SCORES AND THE WAY THE
STATE TESTS KIDS AND ALL THE
OTHER TESTING THAT DISTRICTS ARE
PUTTING ON TEACHERS SO IT'S NOT
JUST THE STATE TETE TESTY BUT
IT'S ALSO INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS
THAT PUT THEIR OWN TESTING ON.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE CURRICULUM
BOOKS THAT PUT TESTING ON. IN
ORDER FOR THOSE KIDS TO DO WELL
THIS STUFF GETS CUT OUT SOME OF
THE DISCONNECT HOW YOU THAT WE
CAN GO AROUND IN CIRCLES TALKING
ABOUT THIS AND WE CAN TALK FOR
WEEKS AND DAYS. BUT THE TRUTH IS
YOU HAVE TO GO INTO THOSE
CLASSROOMS AND YOU HAVE TO SEE
ABOUT WHAT IS EXPECTED WITH THE
TOOLS THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND TO
EVEN GET JUST IMAGINE THIRTY
THIRD GRADERS. ON TO ALL KINDS
OF COMPUTER STUFF AND FINING THE
CHARGERS THAT WORK AND FINDING
YOU KNOW WHO'S COMPUTER DOESN'T
LOAD UP AND WHO DOESN'T KNOW
THEIR NUMBER TO GET AND. THESE
YOU HAVE TO BE IN THERE TO SEE
THIS AND IT ISN'T THAT IT CAN'T
HAPPEN BUT YOU CAN'T TAKE ALL
THE OLD STUFF AND SAY NOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO ALL THIS NEW STUFF.
AND THEN WHEN YOU TELL TEACHERS
LET'S GET RID OF THE OLD STUFF
AND START THE NEW STUFF. THEN
WE'RE DOING MORE AND MORE IN
TRAINING AND THEY NEVER REALLY
GOT IT GET GOOD AT ANYTHING THE
TEACHERS THEMSELVES.
SO I YOU KNOW HAVE FOR MY OWN
CHILDREN MY LAST WHEN THE
GRADUATING FROM CAL STATE THIS
THE MASTER. THEY CAME FROM ALL
OF THOSE SWINGS YOU NOW FROM
WHOLE LANGUAGE WHERE CHARTS WERE
FALLING OFF THE CLASSROOM WALLS
AND EVERYBODY'S READING
LITERATURE IN GROUPS AND STUFF
TO NOW WE'RE DOING THE WROTE. UP
WITH WE'VE GOT A NEW PHONICS
ONLY. AND THAT YOU KNOW BUT
BECAUSE I WAS A TEACHER I READ
TO THEM FROM THE TIME THEY WERE
IN PRESCHOOL I HAD EARLY READERS
IN KINDERGARTEN. BUT IT WAS LIKE
THE FIRST FIVE WHERE WE READ WE
SAYING WE GET BUT AGAIN. NOT
EVERYBODY DOES THAT SO
EVERYTHING IN HERE THE PIPELINE
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH ANY OF IT
BUT I GUESS AS THE PANELS GO ON
AND I HEAR PEOPLE. JUST THAT
SOMEHOW WE HAVE TO TAKE THE
REALITY.
WITH WHAT WE WANT.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GET
THERE I JUST WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
SOME TEACHERS HERE BECAUSE IT
ISN'T THAT THEY SHOULDN'T. I
MEAN IN MY OPINION YOU SHOULD
SPEND ALL DAY ONE DAY JUST
DOING.
PROJECT BASED LEARNING AND HAVE
EVERYTHING OUT ON THE TABLES AND
THEY'RE PUTTING THINGS TOGETHER
IN THEIR FIXING THINGS AND THEN
MAYBE A WHOLE NOTHER DAY WE'RE
DOING ALL LITERATURE. BUT IF YOU
GO INTO A CLASSROOM THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE STANDARDS UP AND NOW
WE'RE DOING EMAIL DE AND NOW
WE'RE GOING OUT P. E. SO. JUST
KEEP THAT IN MIND HE KEEPS
SMILING SO I KNOW HE KNOWS
SOMETHING FFF. AFTER THE IT'S
NOT TO BE NEGATIVE I LOVE
EDUCATORS I LOVE ALL OF THE
OPTIONS UP THERE BUT IT'S TO BE
PRACTICAL.
THANK YOU YEAH I THINK THAT.
SIMILAR KRYSTLE OR ON POINTS
OUT. THAT THERE ARE SOMETIMES
PRACTICAL BARRIERS THAT NEED TO
BE CONSIDERED EVEN WHEN IT COMES
TO THE BEST RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE HAVE.
YEAH AND I CAN'T FORGET THE
CONVERSATION THAT SCENE I HAD
ABOUT KIDS KEY BEING GIVEN
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS INCOMPLETE.
BEING GIVEN GREAT COMPUTERS AND
THERE'S NO MOUSE TO WORK WITH
THE COMPUTER. OF THIS NO
KEYBOARD TO THINGS THAT ARE
MISSING.
AND WE OFTEN DO HERE TEACHER
SAY THAT IF THEY WERE TO
IMPLEMENT ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT COME DOWN FROM THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. THERE WOULD BE
ENOUGH HOURS IN THE DAY TO DO
THAT AND SO AN ARMY JUST JUMP IN
AND THE ONE THING THAT REALLY
JUMPS OUT AT ME AS A STATE
TESTING FOR THIRD GRADE. ART
REQUIRES THAT THEY ACTUALLY
WRITE AN ESSAY ON THE COMPUTER A
THREE PARAGRAPH KIND OF WELL PUT
TOGETHER ESSAY AT THIRD GRADE.
MOST OF I WOULDN'T SAY ALL BUT A
GOOD AMOUNT CAN DO THAT AND
PAPER AND PENCIL IT'S STILL
ROUGH BUT THEY CAN DO IT. BUT A
GOOD MAJORITY CANNOT DO IT ON
THE COMPUTER BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T HAD ANY TYPE OF
KEYBOARDING.
AND A LOT OF THE SCHOOLS AND
THEY DO HAVE THE KEYBOARDS.
FOR THE TEST BUT THEY SAVED THE
KEYBOARDS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT THEM RUINED.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THE SAME STATE TEST YOU YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THOSE THINGS SO THEY
DON'T GET THE PRACTICE NOW SOME
OF THE FAMILIES WHO KNOW ABOUT
THAT LET THEM GO ON LINE AND YOU
KNOW WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO
THAT BUT AGAIN WE KNOW THERE. IS
WHERE THE GREAT DIVIDE HAPPENS I
AM THAT SHE MEANT GAP THERE WILL
BE FAMILIES THAT WILL PUT HIM ON
ONLINE AND AND YOU KNOW HELP
THEM LEARN THAT.
SO IT IT'S AGAIN THAT ASKING OR
MAKING OR MANDATING AND THEN THE
REALITY.
SO I'M GONNA RECOMMEND WE DO TWO
THINGS ONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND IRE ARE
GONNA WORK ON SOME THINGS LONG
TERM WITH THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND. OUT THERE NEEDS
TO BE AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR
HOW TO IMPLEMENT. ALL OF THESE
GREAT RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE STATE BOARD RECENTLY CAME
UP WITH A GREAT.
BLUEPRINT IN ANOTHER AREA HOW
TO IMPLEMENT.
NEW BEST PRACTICES AROUND
BILINGUAL EDUCATION.
I THINK WE NEED A SIMILAR ROAD
MAP FOR MANY TOPICS INCLUDING UP
WHAT WE DO AROUND STEM.
SO THAT WE SO THAT WE FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MANAGE ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS AND PROVIDE THESE
GREAT RECOMMENDATIONS IN WAYS
THAT ACTUALLY.
CAN BE ACHIEVED FOR STUDENTS
AND SO.
THAT'S A LONG TERM WORK THAT'S
A LONG TERM HOME ASSIGNMENT I'M
EXCITED TO WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SUNDAY
GONNA BE KEEPIN IT REAL. AND
BRINGING SOME PRACTICAL
INSIGHTS.
FROM WHAT YOU'VE EXPERIENCE IN
THE CLASSROOM TO HELP US REMOVE
THE BARRIERS TO GET AWAY OF
ACTUALLY MAKING THESE THINGS
HAPPEN.
I'LL ASK EACH PANELIST IF YOU
HAVE A FOUGHT TO A CORPORATE
THAT IN YOUR PRESENTATION.
IF NOT WE'LL SAVE IT FOR THE
QUEUE IN A.
AND SO.
SO THAT WE GET TO THE PANELISTS.
MRS STUART VIA IF YOU WANNA
JUST A MINUTE TO ADDRESS US SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW WE DO
THAT WHILE WE DO THAT AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE THROUGH THE REST OF
THE CAMP.
CERTAINLY AND AND THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN THURMAN SO I THINK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
RAISES SOME VERY VERY GOOD
POINTS.
I DON'T THINK AT LEAST IN MY
MIND THAT THIS IS AN EITHER OR
PROPOSITION I THINK BOB
CERTAINLY WHEN IT COMES TO
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
TEACHERS TKD EIGHT. I THINK IT
IS REALLY MORE ABOUT HOW DO WE
INTEGRATE OF MATH AND SCIENCE
AND STEM. WITH IN E. LA AND AND
AND MATH QUITE HONESTLY BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT'S WHERE THE FOCUS
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TESTING.
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S THAT
INTEGRATION AND A HOLISTIC
APPROACH AS OPPOSED TO ADDING
ON.
I ALSO THINK THAT THERE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OUT OF SCHOOL TIME MANY OF OUR
REGIONAL NETWORKS ARE REALLY
LEVERAGING WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT
OF SCHOOL. AND AND AND WORKING
HARD TO ENSURE THAT THAT IS
CONNECTED STRONGLY TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
SO THERE'S SOME SOME STRONG
LINKAGE THERE. AND THEN THERE
ALSO INFORMAL OPPORTUNITIES
AROUND STEM THAT I THINK COULD
BE LEVERAGED.
GREAT INTEREST AROUND MAKER
SPACES SO I THINK IT IS REALLY
ABOUT HOW DO WE CONNECT THE
DOTS.
THE MANY OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO US TO TOUCH PARENTS
FAMILIES AND AND AND STUDENTS.
SO THAT THEY GET A MUCH.
BETTER EDUCATION THERE'S
GREATER EXPOSURE AND THEY
ACTUALLY GET TO WHERE THEY NEED
TO BE IN TERMS OF THEIR UP
PERFORMANCE AND ACHIEVEMENT SO
I%
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL TIME
TO RESPOND. OUT THANK YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU RAISE A GOOD POINT WE
DISCUSSED IT BRIEFLY EARLIER IN
THE FIRST PANEL IMPORTANCE OF
INTEGRATING.
YOU KNOW SITE CONCEPTS IN IN
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE CURRICULUM
AND I AGREE IT'S NOT AN EITHER
OR.
PROPOSITION AND.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT TOM HOW WE
USE A NIGHT CLASS TIME.
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AND I
ARE GOING FORWARD A BILL THAT
WOULD FOCUS ON HOW WE PROVIDE
MORE STEM SUPPORT DURING THE
AFTER SCHOOL HOURS IT SPONSORED
BY. ON TECHNET AND THEIR MANY
THERE WHO BELIEVE THAT I'M SOME
OF THE BEST WORK AROUND STEM.
HAPPENS DURING THE AFTER SCHOOL
pWE THINK THAT THERE'S A. LOT
LESS USED A WHOLE DAY THE WHOLE
SCHOOL DAY ON TO SUPPORT THESE
EFFORTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AREN'T WELCOME YOU MISS LOUIS
HERE YOUR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU AND I THINK SOME OF MY
COMMENTS WERE ACTUALLY ADDRESSED
TO THE ROLE OF BUSINESS. AND HOW
THE COMPLIMENT.
THE PROMOTION OF STEM OUTSIDE
OF THE SCHOOL DAY SIDE FIRST
LIKE TO THANK CHAIRMAN TONY
THURMOND AND SELECT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF STEM AS IT RELATES
TO THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
MY ORGANIZATION IS THE EAST BAY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ALLIANCE
WHERE EAST BAY EDA. WHERE CROSS
SECTOR HIGH LEVEL LEADERSHIP
GROUP DEDICATED TO BUILDING
ECONOMIC DICK WEALTH AND
PRESERVING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
IN THE EAST BAY WE UTILIZE CROSS
SECTOR LEADERSHIP? REGIONAL
MARKETING RESEARCH ADVOCACY AND
BUSINESS ENGAGEMENT TO ACHIEVE
OUR GOALS.
TEN YEARS AGO CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES CONVENED
EDUCATION AND BUSINESS LEADERS
IN AND INNOVATION AND ONE POINT
OVER RUPE. TO DISCUSS WAYS THE
UNITED STATES COULD REMAIN
GLOBE.
AND THIS RESULTED IN TWENTY ONE
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
SENATE ON TEACHER PREPARATION
CURRICULUM AND THE DELIVERY OF
EDUCATION LAW.
IN FEBRUARY TWENTY SIX
TEAM DURING PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
LAST TERM IN OFFICE HE AND
LEADER PELOSI AFTER UNITED
STATES HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
FOLLOW UP WITHIN INNOVATION TWO
POINT OH CONVENING TO REEXAMINE
THE NATION'S GLOBAL
COMPETITIVENESS IN LIGHT OF HOW
TECHNOLOGY HAD CHANGED THE
WORLD.
OUR UNITED STATES HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE EAST
BAY CONGRESSWOMAN LEGAL
CONGRESSMAN SWALWELL CONGRESSMAN
TO SONG A INVITED REGIONAL
LEADERS TO RESTART THE DIALOGUE
IN APRIL OF THAT YEAR.
SEVERAL OF THE ATTENDEES OF THE
INNOVATION TWO POINT OH MEETINGS
REQUESTED THAT A PLAN OF ACTION
BE DEVELOPED TO ENGAGE BUSINESS
AND EDUCATION TO PROMOTE STEM
EDUCATION.
MY ORGANIZATION WAS ASKED TO
RECONVENE THE GROUP IN OCTOBER
OF THAT YEAR TO SOLICIT MORE
DETAILED INPUT ON LONG AND SHORT
TERM ACTION ITEMS.
ALL OUR EMPLOYER ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WAS TASKED WITH
DOCUMENTING THE DISCUSSION INTO
A FORMAL REGIONAL STEM ACTION
PLAN. THAT BUSINESS
GOVERNMENT EDUCATORS AND THE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY COULD
EMBRACE.
OUR EMPLOYER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
CO CHAIR TRINA OSTRANDER IN FROM
FROM HOW CAN A CAL STATE EAST
BAY.
AND ALSO THE HEAD OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR STEM EDUCATION.
IS HERE TODAY AND SHE WAS VERY
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE PROCESS AND
BY THE WAY SHE WILL BE INDUCTED
INTO THE ALAMEDA COUNTY WOMEN'S
HALL OF FAME IN TWO WEEKS.
SO THIS DISCUSSION IN THIS WORK
FROM COMMITTEE CULMINATED INTO A
FORMAL INNOVATION TO POINT ONLY
SHALL STEM ACTION PLAN. WHICH
I'VE BROUGHT OUT COPIES FOR ALL
OF YOU TODAY AND IS ALSO VISIBLE
ON OUR WEBSITE WE ROLLED HIS
PLANNED OUT IN ME. WITH OUR
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS WHO THEN
BROUGHT THE PLAN BACK TO
WASHINGTON DC TO SHARE WITH THE
COLLEAGUES.
THIS WAS THE NATION'S VERY FIRST
UPDATE TO THE ORIGINAL
INNOVATION A ONE POINT OH PLAN
AND WE'RE VERY PROUD AND HONORED
TO HAVE A KEY ROLE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT.
THE NEED FOR THIS PLAN TODAY IS
GREATER THAN EVER.
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN COMPETITIVE
NESS AND FEELS THAT REQUIRES
STEM SKILLS. OUR BUSINESS
LEADERS NEED ACCESS TO HOME
GROWN TALENT.
TO MAKE TODAY MANY OF OUR JOBS
HERE AT HOME OR OUT SOURCED
THROUGH H. ONE B. VISAS OR
COMPANIES ARE FINDING THEMSELVES
HIRING TALENT WHO LIVE FARTHER
AWAY FROM OUR JOB CENTERS. AND
THAT CONTRIBUTES TO TRAFFIC
CONGESTION POOR AIR QUALITY AND
A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT TO THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES.
AND THIS IS NOT A SUSTAINABLE
WAY TO CAPTURE A SKILLED
WORKFORCE.
EMPLOYERS ARE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT WAYS THEY CAN BE
ENGAGED IN THE EDUCATION OF
STUDENTS TO PROMOTE THEIR
ADOPTION OF STEM SKILLS AND STEM
RELATED CAREERS.
EMPLOYERS KNOW THAT EVEN WHEN
THEY SHARE THEIR TRAINING NEEDS
WITH EDUCATORS.
SKILL REQUIREMENTS CAN CHANGE
FREQUENTLY WITH TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATION FASTER THAN A
CURRICULUM CAN BE DEVELOPED
TEACHERS CAN BE PREPARED AND CAN
EVEN ASSEMBLED STUDENTS TO COME
IN THE CLASSROOM.
PARA PLAYERS OPEN THEIR DOORS TO
YOUTH FAMILIES AND TEACHERS ON
NATIONAL MANUFACTURING DAY TO
DEMYSTIFY WHAT FACTORIES LOOK
LIKE A SHOW HOW ROBOTICS AND
TECHNOLOGY ARE KEY. TO THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS.
BUSINESS VOLUNTEERS MEET WITH
YOUTH ON STEM CAREER AWARENESS
DAYS TO DISCUSS WHAT THEY
STUDIED WHEN THEY WENT TO SCHOOL
WHAT KIND OF JOBS THEY HOLD AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY WITH THE
EARNED.
THE SHOW DIFFERENT TYPES OF JOBS
ACROSS INDUSTRIES THAT NOW
REQUIRES STEM SKILLS AND THESE
AREN'T JUST JOBS IN LABS THEIR
CAR DEALERSHIPS BAKERIES.
CONSTRUCTIONS FIGHTS AND FOOD
PROCESSING COMPANIES.
I WOULD THE VERY VERY YOUNG PRE
KINDERGARTEN AGE CHILDREN
BUSINESS VOLUNTEERS CONDUCT
EXPERIMENTS AND MATH PUZZLES AT
LOCAL CHILDREN VENUES LIKE OUR
ANNUAL FAIRYLAND DAY. AND
COMMUNITY LAPSED MANY WHICH ARE
FUNDED ACTUALLY BY BUSINESS.
ALL OF THESE ARE TO ACT ALL
THESE ACTIVITIES ARE REPLICABLE
SCALABLE AND IMPACTFUL AND WITH
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES CAN REACH
MORE YOUTH WHO NEED THIS DAMN
ORIENTATION AND MOTIVATION. AND
THE LONG TERM GOAL OF ALL THIS
BUSINESS ENGAGEMENT IS TO
ADDRESS THE AFOREMENTIONED
CONCERN OF DEVELOPING A LOCAL.
TALENTED AND DIVERSE WORKFORCE
READY TO HIRE.
YOU WILL SEE MANY EMPLOYER LET
STRATEGIES IN THE INNOVATION TO
PLANO REGIONAL STEM ACTION PLAN
BECAUSE BUSINESSES REALIZE STEM
APTITUDE IS NOT A LUXURY. IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO BUSINESS SUCCESS
EMPLOYEES SAID SUSTAINABILITY
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES AND YES
GLOBAL COMPETITIVENESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO WHERE WE LOOK FOR
TALKING WITH YOU MORE ABOUT THE
COMPANY SAID SUPER
YOUR EFFORTS AND SUPPORT OUR
EFFORTS.
AND THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
OUR THIS YEAR TO FAIRYLAND DATE
WAS A GREAT EVENT THANK YOU.
I'LL DOT TO LIVE AND WE WELCOME
YOUR TESTIMONY. OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR INVITING ME AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR REMARKS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
.
I'VE I'M AB MAYBE UNIQUE PERSON
IN THIS ROOM BECAUSE I'M THE
ONLYPEDIATRICIAN. AND ARE
PROBABLY THE OLDEST PERSON IN
THIS ROOM BUT I'VE BEEN A
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN OAKLAND
FOR FIFTY YEARS. AND I STARTED
HEMATOLOGY ONCOLOGY THAN I'VE
DIRECTED TO RESEARCH PROGRAM AND
NOW ON THE ASSOCIATE DEAN FOR
CHILDREN'S HEALTHY UCSF.
I AM MY COMMITMENT IS TO SOCIAL
JUSTICE IN EQUITY AND I AM SO
PLEASED AND PROUD TO HEAR ALL
THE PRESENTATIONS THAT OCCURRED
TODAY. ANDTHE COMMITMENT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO REALLY
ADDRESSING A MAJOR MAJOR
PROBLEM.
BUT I THINK. TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM WE ALSO HAVE TO THINK OF
ALL THE FACTORS THAT AFFECT
HEALTH EDUCATION IS HEALTH. BUT
WHEN A FAMILY HAS NO ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD WHEN THERE'S NO FOOD
ON THE TABLE.
WHEN THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY FOR
EDUCATION AT ALL AND WITH
THERE'S SO MUCH STRESS PLACED
ON.
I HAVE DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING
HOW WE'RE GOING TO IMPLEMENT ALL
THE WONDERFUL THINGS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY WHICH ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
BE IMPLEMENTED AND HOW IF WE
WANT TO ADDRESS EQUITY. THOSE
KIDS THAT ARE THE MOST STRESSED
ARE GOING TO BE THE LEAST LIKELY
TO BENEFIT FROM THIS SO I THINK
IS WE THINK OF OUR PLAN.
OF HOW WE IMPLEMENT THIS WE
REALLY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT. THE
KIDS THAT ARE MARGINALIZED IN
OUR SOCIETY AND THAT THAT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
BROUGHT INTO THIS.
DECADES AGO WITH THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH FUNDED
SOMETHING CALLED SCIENCE
EDUCATION PARTNERSHIPS
SEPA AND WE HAD ONE IN OAKLAND.
AND WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE TEACHER'S ROLE I REMEMBER
ARE MAJOR ISSUES TEACHERS SAID
THEY LOVE THIS THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY TIME IN THE DAY. AND WHEN
CAN WE DO THIS AND WAS THERE A
COMMITMENT FROM FROM THE HIGHER
REPS TO REALLY PRIMITIVISTS SO
WE WENT TO AFTER SCHOOL AND WE
ALSO SHOWED THAT. PARENTS NEED
TO BE PART OF THE WHOLE PROCESS.
AND WHEN I CAME IN TODAY I SAW
THESE ALL THESE YOUNG CHILDREN
RUNNING AROUND DOWNSTAIRS WHERE
AND I THOUGHT. THERE ARE
PROBABLY NOBEL LAUREATES IN THAT
GROUP THEY ARE NEVER GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN TO REALLY
DEVELOP TO WHAT THEY CAN. AND IN
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE HAD AS
PILOT PROJECTS A CHILDREN'S IN
OAKLAND WE HAVE RECOGNIZED THE
QUALITY OF THOSE CHILDREN. AND
MANY OF THE TEENAGERS
ESPECIALLY.
IF YOU TRY TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM. THOSE
THAT ARE GOING TO WORK HARDEST
ARE THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY
WORKING HARD TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES.
SO WE HAVE TO REALIZE IF YOU
HAVE ANOTHER PROGRAM WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO DO FOR THEIR
OVERALL TO KEEP THEIR FAMILIES
TOGETHER AND I THINK IS WE THINK
OF THESE NEW EDUCATIONAL THINGS.
THERE HAVE TO BE SOME RESOURCES
TO DO IT SO WE HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT AT OUR RESEARCH INSTITUTE
IT'S FUNDED BY THE AND I H. IT'S
FINE ADVICE ARM. CALIFORNIANS
INTO FOR REGENERATIVE MEDICINE
SURROUNDED BY DORIS DUKE IT'S
ALL WRITTEN UP IN THE MATERIALS
THAT YOU HAVE BUT IT HAS A
STIPEND. AND AS FOR UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS AND IF IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE STIPEND THEY COULDN'T
TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY. I'M
BECAUSE THEY SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES
THESE ARE THE KIDS THAT THAT
THAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO. SAY
THERE'S ANOTHER CAREER AND IT'S
AMAZING.
I CAPABILITIES THEY HAVE AND
THEIR HOPE AT THE END OF
DECEMBER THAT THEY COULD DO
SOMETHING MORE THAN THEY THOUGHT
THEY COULD DO BEFORE. AND I
THINK OF ALL THE PRESENTATIONS I
HEARD TODAY WHICH WERE WONDERFUL
HOPE IS ALL PART OF IT. HERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE YOUR LIFE
BETTER AND I'M I'M REALLY PROUD
OF THAT ANOTHER PROGRAM WE HAVE
IS IT'S CALLED THE CHAMPS
PROGRAM WHERE WE WORK WITH THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AND GIVE A
OPPORTUNITY THESE ARE ALL THAT I
THINK ATTACHED IN YOUR BROCHURE
OUT FOR STUDENTS TO GET CREDIT
WORKING AT THE HOSPITAL. EYES
DOING. MEDICAL THINGS THINKING
ABOUT CAREERS IN MEDICINE SO WE
HAVE A SCIENCE PROGRAM AND WE
HAVE A CAREER PROGRAM.
BUT I THINK IF YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT ALL THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THEIR MANY WONDERFUL ONES THEY
ALL DO THIS.
AND THEY CALL THEM A LITTLE
DIFFERENT BUT EVERYBODY HAS A
PROGRAM
ALL THE UNIVERSITIES HAVE
PROGRAMS.
AND IN THE HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
ALL THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS WE
NEED TO COORDINATE THAT TOGETHER
I HEARD SO MANY WONDERFUL THINGS
TODAY. THAT IF WE CAN NETWORK
THIS WITH YOUR BILL.
WE COULD REALLY MAKE THIS STATE
THE LEADER IN THE WORLD AND I I
KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO TRY
TO ACCOMPLISH. AND I AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO DO WITH THE TERM YOU
USED WHICH.
DOCTOR NEVER ARE AND I ARE
FACED WITH EVERY DAY IS BEST
PRACTICE.
WHAT IS THE BEST PRACTICE TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS AND I THINK WE
CAN DO THIS HERE AND I THINK IF
YOU TAKE? ADVANTAGE OF ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
STATE AND WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
WE HAVE A REALLY REALLY
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY. AND WE
NEED TO REALLY ADDRESS MORE THAN
JUST EDUCATIONAL GAP IF WE WON
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT COULD OCCUR
IF WE DON'T LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
HOUSING FOOD A JOB OPPORTUNITIES
I GAVE.
THE A I'M NOT PATTING MYSELF HER
BETTER HAVE A COUPLE YEARS AGO I
WAS FORTUNATE TO GET A TED TALK
ON POVERTY IS A DISEASE OF
CHILDREN.
AND IT IT SIDE YOU TO BET IT'S
BETTER BETTER REALLY TALKS ABOUT
EDUCATION FITTING AND IF YOU
DON'T ADDRESS THE POVERTY
CHALLENGE.
THEN HOW YOU COULD EDUCATE
SPECIALLY IF YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
EQUITY SO THE KIDS THAT HAVE
COMPUTERS WITH MASSES AT HOME
THEY HAVE MONEY. AND THEY HAVE
THOSE RESOURCES FOR THEIR
FAMILIES THOSE THAT DON'T DOWN.
AND LASTLY AND THERE'S A
ORGANIZATION CALL YOU S. SPIRE I
NEVER HEARD OF THIS BEFORE BUT
THIS IS A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION.
THAT HELPS KIDS APPLY TO COLLEGE
DOES THE PAPERWORK HELPS BECAUSE
MANY FAMILIES ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT TO DO IN THE KIDS
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO AND. NEXT
WEEK I'M GIVIN AND GET A RECEIVE
THE HONORARY AWARD FOR THIS
COMMITMENT FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR ASPIRE FOR KIDS.
SOUND.
SO AS A PEDIATRICIAN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE GOOD YOU
DO BECAUSE THE FUTURE OF OUR
SOCIETY IS IN THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
DO NO NORMALLY WE KNOW WE'RE
TOLD NOT TO ALLOW ON THE
APPLAUSE IN THIS CHECK.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T FALL RULES ARE
GOOD FOR KIDS GOOD PEOPLE AND.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY WHO WHO
DESERVE THE RECOGNITION AND
DOCTOR LUBIN AND INTRIGUE
OSTRANDER FOR YOUR RECOGNITION
SOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA.
I'M.
UP FIRST I HOPE THAT MISTER
STEWART DOESN'T THINK I WASN'T
BEING POSITIVE ABOUT I I WAS
JUST TRYING TO BE. LIKE COMBINE.
PRACTICAL AND REALITY WITH NEW
INNOVATION AND EXCITEMENT.
A AND I DO THINK IT DOES AS THE
DOCTOR LEVINE SAYS YOU KNOW KIDS
HAVE TO HAVE HOPE AND IT REALLY
STARTS WITH THE VERY BASICS.
WHEN I STARTED TEACHING AT
TWENTY. ONE OR TWENTY TWO YEARS
OLD I. I ACTUALLY TAUGHT IN
PHILLY TEN AT WHAT WE'D CALL
HILL SCHOOL IN FULLERTON
ACTUALLY HAS HILLS AND AND SO IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE UPPER.
TYPE OF SCHOOL WITH THE.
OF THE LOT OF FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
AND YOU KNOW THAT DOESN'T MEAN
AT THAT SCHOOL THERE WASN'T ANY
ISSUES AT ALL BUT IT DEFINITELY
WOULD MOST OF THE MOMS AT THAT
TIME. YOU KNOW IN THE EIGHTIES
WERE STAYING HOME AND SO HOLD
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT. AND THEN
I CHOSE TO TO MOVE TO THE SCHOOL
I ACTUALLY ATTENDED IN FULLERTON
A WHICH IS A TITLE ONE SCHOOL
AND SPENT MOST OF MY UP YEARS
TEACHING THERE. AND WHEN I FIRST
STARTED TEACHING MY WHOLE KIND
OF PASSION FOR TEACHING WAS
ABOUT CREATIVITY IT WAS ABOUT.
THINGS THAT I LIKE TO DO
WHETHER IT BE OUR TOUR LIKE I
SAID VIETNAM. BIG CINEMATIC
THINGS ON LITERATURE RAN AND
WRITING AND AND YOU KNOW AND AND
MAYBE I WEAVER DURING THE MASS
OUR WAY SO YOU KNOW I REALLY
ENJOYED THAT TOO. BUT THERE WERE
A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON IN
EDUCATION WE DIDN'T HAVE
DISCUSSIONS THIRTY YEARS AGO
ABOUT ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. WHEN I MOVE BACK TO
THE SCHOOL THAT I HAD ACTUALLY
GONE TO.
OF COURSE IT WAS A WHOLE
DIFFERENT.
ISSUE AND EVEN THOUGH THOSE.
IT DEMOCRATS AS WERE VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME I LEARNED VERY
QUICKLY THAT IF A KID OR A
STUDENT HAS AN ABSCESS BECAUSE
THEY HAVEN'T HAD DENTAL CARE.
OR LIKE YOU SAY THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY'RE SLEEPING. ARM AT
NIGHT LOW'S ARE ALL THINGS THAT
HAPPEN IN THEIR DAY BEFORE YOU
EVEN GET TO THE CURRICULUM.
BEFORE YOU EVEN GET TO THE BEST
PRACTICES. AND WAY BACK TWENTY
YEARS AGO SOME OF YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER THERE WAS A GRANT.
THROUGH THE STATE CALLED HEALTHY
START
AND THIS THIS GRANT WAS REALLY.
FORM TO MAKE CONNECTIONS WITH
IN YOUR DISTRICT SO WHAT WHETHER
IT BE BUSINESS.
OR OTHER CONNECTIONS THAT
DIDN'T START A NEW PROGRAM THAT
BUT YOU WOULD BE A LIAISON IN
YOUR COMMUNITY TO GO OUT.
AND MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS SO
ONE CONNECTION WE MADE IN IN
FULLERTON WAS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF OPTOMETRY
WAS RIGHT THERE. SO WE WERE ABLE
TO CONNECT
THEM TO DO EYEGLASS EXAMS AND SO
SURE ENOUGH WHAT DID WE FIND OUT
THAT A LOT OF OUR FIRST GRADERS
NEEDED GLASSES AND WORK. SO IT
WAS KIND OF GOING BACKWARDS IN
DOING SOME OF THE HOLISTIC
ISSUES OUT WE WEE ABLE TO BUILD
A HEALTH CLINIC RIGHT BEHIND OUR
SKILL SCHOOL BECAUSE THEN I WENT
ON CITY COUNCIL ON I REALIZED
HEY. WE CAN GET THINGS DONE WE
PUT LIGHTING AND SO THAT THE
KIDS COULD DO SOCCER AFTER
SCHOOL THAT THE CITY PAID AND IT
WAS A PARTNERSHIP.
BUT IT WHAT REMAINS IS SOME
PEOPLE THINK HOLISTICALLY OR.
I'M I'M DEATHLY KIND LIKE A
HOLISTIC KIND OF PERSON AND THEN
OTHERS BECAUSE OF THE TRAINING
OR BECAUSE OF WHATEVER THEY SEE
THEIR LANDS THROUGH MIGHT SAY
THAT'S NOT MY JOB.
THAT'S A SOCIAL THING WE DON'T
DO SOCIAL THINGS WE DON'T HAVE
COUNSELORS ON SCHOOLS WE DON'T.
IT ISN'T OUR JOB TO ASK
THOSE KIND OF QUESTIONS AND
LATER EVEN ALLOW UP TO THE LAST
FEW YEARS OF TEACHING WHICH IT
WAS ONLY FOR ME IS. LESS THAN IT
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
ONE I'D HAVE STUDENT PARENT
CONFERENCES IT WOULD ALWAYS USED
TO BE YOU WOULD TELL THEM HOW
THEY WERE DOING IN SCHOOL.
AND THEN IT BECAME THIS WHOLE
THING OF JUST GIVEN THE SCORES
AND ALL THIS STUFF.
BUT MY LAST FEW YEARS I DIDN'T
DO ANY OF THOSE THINGS I TOOK
OUT A NOTEBOOK AND ASKED THEM.
WHAT WAS GOING ON BECAUSE OVER
AN OVER THE PARTICULARLY IN THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHEN THINGS JUST?
DECLINED WE HAD KIDS WHO ARE
HOMELESS WE HAD PARENTS WHO
WEREN'T GETTING HEALTH CARE WE
HAD A DREAMER KIDS WHO WERE
OLDER STUDENTS OF MINE NOW
TRYING TO GO TO COLLEGE AND I
WOULD JUST WRITE THIS LIST. AND
BECAUSE I HAD BEEN THE HEALTHY
START COMPORTED NADER AS A
TEACHER I WAS ABLE TO DO THAT ON
SPECIAL ASSIGNMENT. I CAN THEN
MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS AND ONCE
YOU MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS LIVES
DO CHANGE
BECAUSE AND THEN THEY'RE FREED
UP FROM ALL THIS ANXIETY OF A
ONE IN TROUBLE. BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE MY UNIFORM OR I'M BEING
PUNISHED BECAUSE I DIDN'T DO MY
HOMEWORK AND I'M SITTING AT THE
WALL AND I. CAN'T PLAY RICK GO
TO RECESS OR I DON'T GO ON THE
FIELD TRIPS NOW SOME OF THOSE
THINGS HAVE BEEN RECTIFIED WITH
THE LEGISLATION. NOW TEACHERS
CAN'T KEEP KIDS FROM GOING ON
FIELD TRIPS BECAUSE TYPICALLY
THOSE ARE THE KIDS WHO NEED TO
GO ON THE FIELD TRIPS.
SO I THINK THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT.
SPECIFIC CURRICULUM LIKE STEM
I'M A HUGE SUPPORTER BECAUSE ONE
OF THE THINGS I KNOW IS KIDS ARE
DOING THINGS
I MEAN WHEN THE PASSIVE IN A
GROUP WHETHER IT'S LOOKING AT A
COMPUTER SCREEN AND AGAIN NOW
MORE AND MORE AS COMPUTER
LEARNING WE GOT SCREENS IN FRONT
OF US.
A LOT OF TIMES THE CLASSROOMS
ARE DARKENED BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
A SCREEN THERE AND THE KIDS
BECOME A VERY PASSIVE AUDIENCE
OF THE WHOLE POWER POINT THINGS.
I MEAN AND HOW MANY OF US ARE
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE TEN SLIDES
NOT FIFTY BUT THE POINT IS THAT
THEY'RE NOT ACTIVE THEY'RE NOT
MOVING AROUND SO. I'M A BIG
BELIEVER IN STEM BUT AGAIN AS WE
HAVE ALL OF YOU WHO ARE OUR
VOICES ON THE COMMUNITY.
THE FIRST THING THAT THEY CARE
ABOUT.
KIDS CARE ABOUT IS IF THEY'RE
HUNGRY.
THE JUST NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
LEARN AND WE CANNOT FORGET THAT
I CAN'T TELL YOU I HAD BOXES OF
GRANOLA BARS IN MY. DESK AND.
.
I'M NOT TRYING TO PAINT THE
WORST SCENARIO AND BE THE
BLEEDING HEART I'M JUST TRYING
TO TELL YOU. THESE ARE HILL
SCHOOLS IN FULLERTON BECAUSE I
WENT BACK TO THE HILL SCHOOL AT
THAT TOWARDS THE END.
BUT.
CURRICULUM MATTERS AND IT'S
ESSENTIAL IN ENGAGEMENT IS HUGE
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE COMBINING NAM WITH THOSE
HOLISTIC THINGS THAT WE KNOW
KIDS NEED SO THANK YOU DOCTOR
LIBIN.
PROMISE I WON'T SAY THAT MUCH
THAT ANOTHER.
I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT YOU
AND DOCTOR LUBIN POINT OUT THAT
THERE HAVE TO BE SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND EQUITY CONSIDERATIONS TO HOW
WE DO STEM.
IT REMINDS ME THAT WE STARTED
THE STEM. IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION ARE VERY FIRST SESSION
WITH THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
SUPPORTING GIRLS AND WOMEN IN
STEM. WE HAD SOME GREAT PARTNERS
WHEN WE STARTED WITH AND GIRLS
AND WOMEN STAND WEEK.
THAT LED TO US TALKING ABOUT
HOW TO ADDRESS DISPARITY FOR
OTHERS.
WE FOUND OURSELVES IN A
JUVENILE CAN'T.
WITH THE TECH PROVIDER LEADING
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT CODING.
AND.
WHICH WAS BRILLIANT AND I THINK
THE ONLY COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FOR ALLOW ME TO TEACH
CIVICS CLASS TO A GROUP OF HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS WHO FIND THEMSELVES.
IN A JUVENILE CAN.
WHAT BOTHERS ME IS THAT IN
CALIFORNIA YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
GET ARRESTED TO LEARN ABOUT
CODING?
OR RE THAT SHOULD NOT BE YOUR
FIRST INTRODUCTION TO A SECTOR
THAT PROMISES TO PROVIDE A
MILLION AND A HALF JOBS
AND SO I THINK YOU BOTH ARE. ARE
CORRECT IN SAYING WE MUST
ADDRESS THE KIND OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND EQUITY FACTORS SO
THAT ALL THESE GREAT
RECOMMENDATIONS REACH MANY OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE POPULATION SO
WE WANT TO REACH.
AND SO WE GOT A LOT OF IT WORK
TO DO HERE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR THE BEEN FOR
ALWAYS REMINDING US THAT WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND THE IMPACT
POVERTY.
AND GOOD MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
AND REALLY WRAPAROUND SUPPORT TO
MAKE SURE OUR FAMILIES ARE
PREPARE TO TAKE IN ALL THESE
GREAT.
RESOURCES.
I I THINK IT'S A NICE SEGUE TO
THE GREAT WORK THAT YOU SEE A
STAFF IS DOING AROUND MAKING
SURE THAT IN OUR WORK FORCE IT
IS DIVERSE AND CLEARLY WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. AND WE LOOK
FORTY HANDSOME THE GREAT BEST
PRACTICES TAKING PLACE THERE.
WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY
DOCTOR TOMORROW.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING IT'S A PLEASURE FOR ME
TO BE HERE THANK YOU CHAIR FOR
THE INVITATION TO MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. I'M DOCTOR NAY
CHAPMAN NOVARRO AND I AM THE
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR DIVERSITY IN
OUT REACH. AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO.
OUR CAMPUS IS A GRADUATE CAMPUS
ONLY ONE OF THE TEN UC CAMPUSES
SEND REALLY FOCUSED ON HEALTH
SCIENCE EDUCATION IN GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION WE ACTUALLY
LIKE TO THINK OF.
STEAM M. M. WITH EXTRA M. FOR
MEDICINE BECAUSE HEALTH CARE
OBVIOUSLY AS TO MEDICATION IS
CRITICAL FOR THOSE OF US WHO
ARE.
AYE IN THE HEALTHCARE FIELD AS A
VICE CHANCELLOR AND THE CAMPUS
LEADER AN EXPERT ON DIVERSITY
EQUITY INCLUSION INITIATIVES AND
BEST PRACTICES. AS WE SEEK TO
INCREASE THE DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION OF OUR OWN STUDENT
BODY OUR FACULTY AND OUR STAFF
AS WE PROVIDE. PATIENT CARE IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH OUT THE
DOCTOR LIVING ALLUDED TO. WE'RE
HERE TO EDUCATE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND SCIENTIST IN THIS
KIND IN THE STATE.
I AS WELL AS ENGAGING IN
LIFESAVING OUR RESEARCH FOR THE
SECOND LARGEST EMPLOYER I. IN
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO WITH THE LIVER TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES ON OUR
CAMPUS. OUR WORKERS ALSO ENGAGED
IN THE COMMUNITY TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY TO WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH SENSE GO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN OTHER DISTRICTS.
TO SERVE OVER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS WE ALSO HAVE A
STUDENTS.
HAVE SCIENCE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
WHERE WE'RE WORKING WITH THE TO
THE TEACHERS YOU OF TEACHER
SCIENCE CAMP TO HELP THEM TO
TEACH.
AS SCIENCE IN THEIR CLASSROOMS.
I'M A PROFESSOR OF
ANESTHESIOLOGY AND I PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS THE ASSOCIATE DEAN FOR
FACULTY. I'VE BEEN STUDYING AND
WORKING AND LEARNING LEARNING ON
ISSUES RELATED TO STEM AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE DIVERSITY
FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
MY WORK ATUCSF OFFICE WELL AS
MY LIVED EXPERIENCES AS I
COMPLETED BOTH PHARMACY SCHOOL
AND MEDICAL SCHOOL. REALLY DRIVE
MY PASSION FOR STEM EQUITY. AND
LED ME TO SEEK TO BE AND BECOME
THE PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR FOR
REGIONAL COLLABORATION TO EXPAND
AND STRENGTHEN STEM WE
AFFECTIONATELY CALL AT RECESS.
REALLY BRIBING THE PROTEST.
UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITIES IN
STEM.
ARGUABLY AS HAS BEEN STATED IN
ONE OF THE REGIONS THAT IS MOST
DENSELY POPULATED WITH CAREERS
IN TECHNOLOGY SCIENCE. AND
HEALTH CARE UTILIZING A REGIONAL
COLLECTIVE IMPACT STRATEGY WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO ACCESS AND
SUCCESS BY BRINGING TOGETHER ALL
OF THE PARTNERS IN THIS ROOM AND
ALL OF. US WHO'VE BEEN HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY ALONG WITH THE
YOUTH THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO ARE REALLY
NAVIGATING INEQUITIES ON A DAILY
BASIS.
WHEN TO JUST BRIEFLY SHARE MY
PERSONAL STORY BECAUSE ELECTED
ILLUSTRATES SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS.
I KNOW THAT AND WERE IT NOT FOR
MY FAMILY AND MY COMMUNITY
SUPPORT I WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY.
I WAS BORN IN MOBILE ALABAMA
DURING THE NATIONAL SHAME OF JIM
CROW SEGREGATION.
FORTUNATELY WE MOVE TO
CALIFORNIA WHERE I COMPLETED K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN NORTH
HIGHLANDS.
AND I WAS AN EXCELLENT STUDENT
SUCCESSFUL IN MATH AND SCIENCE
BUT I WAS ENCOURAGED.
FACT.
ONE TEACHER SAID YOU'RE YOU ARE
REALLY SMART YOU COULD BE A
GREAT EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT AND
HAD ME TAKING SHORTHAND AND
TYPING WHICH I USED WHEN THEY IN
MEDICAL SCHOOL AS I WAS TAKING
NOTES.
BUT DESPITE THAT I REALLY I
FOUND MY WAY.
AND TEACHERS AND COUNSELORS WITH
THEIR OWN UNCONSCIOUS BIAS YOU
KNOW THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
ABOUT THE THIRD GRADE
PARTICULARLY FOR BLACK MEN.
TEACHERS
I HAVE BEEN COURAGEOUS BIASES
AGAINST OUR KIDS AND SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF TEACHING.
ABOUT STEM PEOPLE HAVE
PRECONCEIVED BIASES ABOUT WHO'S
GONNA SIX SALAR SUCCEED IN THESE
AREAS AND WHO WHAT WHO WILL NOT.
I HAD THE BENEFIT A. OF A
PERSISTENT I MOTHER WHO ACTUALLY
BAT REALLY HELPED ME TO
PERSEVERE AND AYE I DEVELOPED
THAT PERSEVERANCE ALONG THE WAY.
AND.
WITHOUT HAVING HAD A ROLE MODEL
I HAD NEVER SEEN A BLACK WOMAN
PHYSICIAN I HAD NO ROLE MODELS I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE PATHWAYS TO
ACTUALLY. GO TO MEDICAL SCHOOL.
SO I FOUND MY WAY TO PHARMACY
SCHOOL.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL I WAS IN A
SENIOR POSITION OF PHARMACY
SCHOOL THAT I SAW MY FIRST HAND
THE ROLE OF A PHYSICIAN AND
HEALTH CARE TEAM AND I.
WHAT REALIZE THAT THAT WHOLE
HAVE WHAT IT TAKES TO DO THAT I
GAINED CONFIDENCE THAT I? HAD
LACKED BEFORE.
SO WITHOUT ROLE MODELS WITHOUT
MENTORS WITHOUT A PATH THAT
COULD BE EASILY NAVIGATED IT WAS
CIRCUITOUS FOR ME TO FIND MY WAY
AND THESE.
KINDS OF INEQUITIES REALLY
PERPETUATE TODAY THEIR BARRIERS
THAT PERPETUITY INEQUITIES.
MANY YEARS LATER I NEVER WOULD
HAVE ENVISIONED THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN I WOULD BECOME
THE FIRST.
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO EVER
BE A VICE CHANCELLOR. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS HISTORY.
YOU KNOW YOU ASK YOURSELF WHY SO
SLOW YEAH. WHILE.
AND YOU KNOW FOR YOU FIND THAT
LITTLE HAS CHANGED IN THIRTY
YEARS STEM CAREERS IN THE U. S.
CONTINUED TO LACK THE DIVERSITY.
THE PERCENTAGE OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS EMPLOYED INSTANT
CAREERS HASN'T CHANGED OVER THE
PAST THREE DECADES.
WE FIND HAS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER THAT THE EDUCATIONAL
GAPS BEGAN SO EARLY IN MATH.
WITH MATH BEING A PREDICTOR AND
THAT THESE DISCREPANCIES
CONTINUE PERSISTENT EXPAND. OVER
TIME.
ULTIMATELY ONLY TWENTY NINE
PERCENT OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT OF HISPANIC
HIGH SCHOOL. GRADUATES COMPLETE
THE A THROUGH G. CURRICULUM
REQUIRED FOR CS YOU AND FOR YOU
SEE ADMISSION THIS IS COMPARED
TO FIFTY PERCENT ARE WHITE
STUDENTS.
THROUGH THIS REGIONAL
COLLABORATION TO EXPAND AND
STRENGTHEN STEM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA THE SAN FRANCISCO
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
AND ALAMEDA COUNTY. OUT BOARD OF
EDUCATION TO COLLABORATE WITH
OVER A HUNDRED BAY AREA PARTNERS
IN BUSINESS EDUCATION NONPROFIT
AND GOVERNMENT SECTORS AS WELL
AS WITH YOU THAN THEIR FAMILIES
THEMSELVES.
TO REALLY IDENTIFY AND PROMOTE
THE CHANGES NECESSARY TO CREATE
A SEAMLESS SYSTEM CREATING THAT
PATHWAY.
AND AS WE'VE HEARD ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT FINDINGS FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
IS THAT THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO
PURSUE A STEM CAREER. IF AT AN
EARLY AGE THEY SEE PEOPLE WHO
LOOK LIKE THEM.
THEY'RE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR SOLVING PROBLEMS WITH
STEM.
SO WE KNOW THAT WE NEED SOME
INTENTIONALITY FOR THESE
PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES WE HAVE
TO START EARLY WE HAVE TO CREATE
AND CURATE THEIR CURIOSITY AND
INTEREST WE HAVE TO HAVE
ENGAGING ACTIVITIES.
FOR THEM WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES WE HAVE TO CREATE A
CULTURE THAT'S WELCOMING
COLLABORATIVE AND FOSTERS A
POSITIVE SELF IMAGE FOR STUDENTS
WITHIN THE TEACHER DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW DO
WE.
BREAK DOWN THESE BARRIERS THESE
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS BARRIERS THAT.
REALLY.
FOSTER THE STEREOTYPE THREAT
THAT OFTEN OF MINORITIES FEEL.
EXPERIENCE IN THESE FIELDS.
WE HAVE TO OFFER THE HANDS ON
EXPERIENCES WITHIN THE FELL OF
THE FIELD AND WE TALK ABOUT THE
INFORMAL LEARNING DE.
KEEP THESE ARE KEY TO REALLY
MAINTAINING THE ACTRESS AND I AM
PLEASED TO HEAR YOU TALK ABOUT
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND HOW DO
WE THINK ABOUT THAT WE'RE
WORKING IN THE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUBS AND. IN THE YMCA TO REALLY
BRING THE SCIENCE EDUCATION TO
THOSE PROGRAMS THIS WHILE. WE
HAVE TO PROVIDE STEM MENTORS AND
NETWORKS THAT ARE CULTURALLY
ALIGNED. AGAIN YOU NEED TO SEE
OURSELVES IN THESE ROLES WE HAVE
TO EDUCATE AND ENGAGE OUR
FAMILIES ON THE DIMMER DIVERSE
AND EMERGING STEM CAREERS. AS
YOU KNOW FAMILIES ARE SO
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS STUDENT
SUCCESS
WE HAVE TO REACH OUT TO THOSE
PARENTS AND ENGAGE THEM AND HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND. HOW THEY CAN?
PREPARE THEIR STUDENTS AT EARLY
EARLY ON.
SUPPORTING.
OUR COMPREHENSIVE REGIONAL
APPROACH WITH THE COURT NATING
ALLIANCE THE ALIGNMENT BAY AREA
REALLY CREATES THE ESSENTIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO INITIATE AND
SUSTAIN ENGAGEMENT THEREBY
PROVIDING. THE EVIDENCE BASE
CULTURALLY INFORMS PATHWAY FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES I
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME THAT
YOU'VE PROVIDED TO ME TODAY AND
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR NAVARRO YOU
REMIND ME THAT WE STARTED OUT
CALLING THIS.
STEM HEARING.
WE CALL THAT THE.
.
ECOSYSTEM.
THAT WE USE THAT TERM AND I
THINK YOU ADDED SOME
INTENTIONALITY TO THAT TIME
THAT.
FOR US TO BE THINKING ABOUT
MENTORS IN COACHING
OPPORTUNITIES.
INSTITUTIONAL BIAS IN HOW WE
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS ITEM WHERE
WE'RE LUCKY TO HAVE SOMEONE LIKE
YOURSELF WHO PERSISTED.
BEYOND.
AND THAT BIAS AND AND THOSE
MESSAGES THAT COULD HAVE
DETERRED YOU WEAR LUCKYTHAT YOU
ARE HERE WITH US TODAY.
REMINDING US AS I KEEP TELLING
MY DAUGHTER THAT WE SHOULD ALL
BE DREAMING ABOUT BEING AN
ENTREPRENEUR SCIENTISTS ARE AN
INNOVATOR. HOW SHE'S ELEVEN
YEARS OLD AND SHE SAYS SHE'S A
SCIENTIST AND I TELL HER I WANT
YOU TO JUST CLEAN UP AFTER
YOURSELF AND DON'T?
AND DON'T BLOW UP THE HOUSE.
ANYTHING BEYOND THAT I WONDER TO
DREAM ABOUT IT AND I THINK THAT
IN THIS SPACE WE WE HEAR FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALL THE TIME.
STRUGGLE THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO MAKERS SPACES ARE PARTNERS TO
HELP THEM HAVE THE TOOLS FOR
MAKERS SPACES SO THAT OUR OUR
KIDS CAN DREAM AND SO THANK YOU
FOR. I'M GIVING INTENTIONALITY
TO THE USE OF THE TERM BUILDING
A COMPLETE ECOSYSTEM.
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS AND
INCLUDING MENTORING AND ROLE
MODELING AND COACHING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA. COMES QUESTIONS.
I JUST THINK WE HAVE ANOTHER
WOMAN HERE THAT DESERVES A PICK
UP APPLAUSE I MEAN AND LAWS ARE
VITAL. TO ALL THE WOMEN.
AND I ONLY SAY WOMEN BECAUSE
IT'S A IT'S A WOMEN'S. HISTORY
MONTH SO WE'LL JUST GIVE THAT A
GOOD REASON TO GIVE IT OUT A
SHOUT OUT. BEG YOU FOR MAKING
HISTORY.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK ALL OF YOU
ABOUT HOW WE HELPED CREATE THE
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THE.
PRIVATE SECTOR IN THE TECH
COMPANIES AND OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY.
WHO SAY WE DON'T HAVE YOU KNOW
WE DON'T HAVE?
A BENEFACTOR.
YOU KNOW.
LIKE SALES FORCE IN OUR AREA WE
LOVE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED AND THE
CONNECTION FOR PRE K. TWELVE.
COMPUTER SCIENCE DISTRICT IT'S
AMAZING.
AS I WORK WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE WHO
SAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY TECH
PARTNERS OUT WHAT CAN WE DO.
TICKET AND THAT.
ARE DISTRICTS THAT WANT HELP
AROUND THAT YOU SAY MISS LOUIS.
SPENDING THEIR STEM PROGRAMS
BUILDING THEIR MAKER SPACES I'M
WHAT WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING.
TO BECAUSE THE STATE IS NOT
PROVIDING THE DOLLARS TO THE
LOCAL TO LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
I'M THIS IS AN AREA WHERE WE
DEFINITELY NEED THE PARTNERSHIP
AND HELP. OF OUR TECH PARTNERS
IN A BUSINESS COMMUNITIES WHAT
ADVICE WOULD YOU GIVE US FROM
MOVING FORWARD.
ONE OF THE THINGS OUR
ORGANIZATION DOES ANNUALLY IS
CELEBRATE INNOVATION IN OUR
REGION AND WE HAVE AN ANNUAL.
EAST BAY INNOVATION AWARDS.
ALL COMPANIES COMPETE FOR THESE
AWARDS IN DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
AND MANY OF THEM ARE BASED
WHETHER THEY'RE MANUFACTURING OR
ICICI OR. EP WE EVEN HAVE AN
EDUCATIONAL WAR ACTS DUBBED
TARGETED TOWARDS
GROUP TO PROMOTE STEM.
OF WHAT WE DO WITH THESE ARM
COMPANIES IS TO CULTIVATE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE CONNECTIONS
AND THE CONNECTIONS OFTEN. OUR
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE AND DISK
ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIPS SO ONE
CONNECTION.
THAT WHO STRONG AND ONE OF OUR
AWARD WINNERS WAS OF PROGRAM
CONVEX TO TAX.
IT'S FOR OLDER ADULTS BUT IT
WAS A PARTNERSHIP WITH LOTS
PROCEED IS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WORKING WITH LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
NATIONAL LABORATORY. OF
RECOGNIZING THERE WAS A NEED FOR
HIRING ENGIEERING TAX
BUT THAT THE VETS A HAD NOT HAD
THE EXPERIENCE OF. OF BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THE ACCELERATED MATH
THAT WAS NEEDED FOR THIS
POSITION SO THE COLLEGE WAS
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO CREATE THAT.
AND NOW WE HAVE A ROBUST
PROGRAM AND WE WERE ALL ABLE TO
BRING OTHER FINALISTS FROM OUR
INNOVATION AWARDS AND WE NOW
HAVE A POOL OF EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
HIRING FROM THIS TRAINING
PROGRAM.
WE SEE THIS AS A MODEL OF
FLEXIBILITY WITH OUR EDUCATORS
PREPARING PEOPLE FOR WORK AND
THEN PULLING ARM PLAYERS
TOGETHER FOR HIRING. ANOTHER WAY
IS THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
EMPLOYERS THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GIVE THE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT. OF ANY OFF CAN
BUT THEY CAN OPEN THEIR DOORS SO
THEIR OPENING THEIR DOORS THEY
REALIZED THAT THERE ARE MANY
INFLUENCERS IN A YOUNG PERSON'S
LIFE. AND ALTHOUGH WE DO VALUE
EDUCATORS WE KNOW THE FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE. INFLUENCERS WE KNOW
THAT COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE WE
KNOW THAT FAITH LEADERS ARE AND
UNFORTUNATELY OR FORTUNATELY
EVEN LIKE ATHLETES HERBIE
INFLUENCERS.
SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
MESSAGING TO PROMOTE STEM
THROUGH THOSE INFLUENCERS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AS WELL. WILL
WE HAVE BUSINESSES ENGAGE WITH
FAMILIES AND WAS STUDENTS WILLIS
HOW THE BUSINESSES.
OF HAVE A SPOKESPERSON THAT
LOOKS LIKE THE KIDS.
SO YOU KNOW WHEN THEY HAVE LUNCH
WITH THEM AT CAREER STEM
AWARENESS WE WANT THE EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE YOUNGER. CREW CAME FROM
INNER CITY NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
LOOKED LIKE THEM THAN WE HAVE
TAUGHT TUESDAY MATH PIERCINGS
BUT THE STUDENTS CAN RELATE TO
THEM AND SAY. I CAN DO THIS
BECAUSE YOU DID THIS.
SO THOSE ARE IN WAYS THAT
BUSINESSES CAN PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT THAT PROMOTION OF STEM
EDUCATION AND ASPIRATIONS FOR
STEM CAREERS WITHOUT HAVING THE
ABILITY TO GIVE A LARGE AMOUNT
OF CASH.
AND IT'S VERY FULFILLING FOR THE
COMPANIES AS WELL THEY LOVE IT
THEY PROVIDE INTERNSHIPS THEY
PROVIDE JOB SHADOWING. AND.
AS MANY OF OUR EMPLOYERS THEY
ARE BEING ONE OF THEM ALL THEY
DO PICK UP A LOT OF THEIR
INTERNS INTO STABLE EMPLOYMENT
WITH THE COMPANY.
IF YOU.
OTHER PANELS.
OUT OF TWELVE IT UCSF SIMILARLY
WE ARE CERTAINLY PARTNERING WITH
MANY IN THE BIOTECH INDUSTRY
GENENTECH IS A BIG PARTNER. I'D
ADDITION KELLY OUT AND WE HAVE A
AN OPPORTUNITY WITH THROUGH A
SEVERAL PROGRAMS WHEN A BRIDGE
TO BIOTECH WHICH IS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY
COLLEGE. IN SAN FRANCISCO TO
TAKE THE CITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
WE USE OUR UNIVERSITY LABS IS A
PLACE FOR THEM TO GET THEIR
INTERNSHIP. AND TRAINING
EXPERIENCES AND THEN MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE BOOK BIOTECH
SPECIALLY AS WE'VE GROWN THE
MISSION BAY CAMPUS SEE US AS A
PLACE FOR THEM TOTAKE OUR
GRADUATES. INTO THEIR
INSTITUTIONS SO WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH THEM AND THEY
WANT OUR GRADUATES ARE THERE
THEY BE FIVE THEY PROVIDE A
CONDUIT FOR OUR. OUR CURRENT TO
AND TO ANTICIPATING STUDENTS TO
ACTUALLY BRIDGE THOSE I'M DIVIDE
ACROSS BUSINESS AND IT'S REALLY
ESSENTIAL FOR OUR STUDENTS TO
HAVE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AND
IT'S AN ESSENTIAL FOR THE. IS
INSTITUTIONS TO HAVE OUR
RESOURCES WELL WE LOVE THE
BRIDGE TO BIOTECH.
NOT JUST BECAUSE I WORK THERE
TWENTY YEARS AGO.
.
BUT BECAUSE IT LET US KNOW THAT
THERE ARE JOBS IN BIOTECH THAT
EVENIF YOU DON'T HAVE A DEEP
SCIENCE BACKGROUND YOU CAN WORK
IN AND THAT HE WAS THE BEST
PART.
THE MORE YOU LEARN THE MORE YOU
CAN AND YOU CAN KEEP GROWING
CLIMBING AND SO WE LOVE THOSE
PROGRAMS I WANNA SUPPORT THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT AND SO THE ONLY
THING I WANTED TO ADD TO WHAT'S
BEEN SAID IS THAT. MANY PLACES
HAVE TO HAVE A CAMINO BENEFIT
ACTIVITY AND THEY REALLY NEED TO
BE AWARE THAT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY KAISER I'M SURE IS
ALREADY DOING IT. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A REALLY BROAD COMMUNITY
BENEFIT ACTIVITY BUT BUT THAT
THIS COULD BE THEIR COMMUNITY
BENEFIT ACTIVITY AND THEY MAY
NOT BE AWARE OF IT. SO AS PART
OF THIS NETWORKING IS SAYING
WELL HERE'S A WAY TO REALLY
CONSIDER AS A COMMUNITY BENEFIT
OPPORTUNITY. WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY BECAUSE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY I THINK?
THANK YOU MISTER SEWER HERE AND
I THINK BUILDING ON THAT I THINK
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF REALLY
IMPRESSIVE PROGRAMS WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY HAS STEPPED
IN. AND SUPPORTED SOMEWHAT
LOCALIZED REGIONAL PROGRAMS MANY
COMPANIES WILL SUPPORT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE AFFILIATED WITH THEIR
OWN LOCATIONS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND THAT SORT OF
THING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK
THE COMMITTEE COULD DO IS HOW
CAN WE BRING THAT CONVERSATION
AND BROUGHT IT TO WHERE WE BRING
IN BUSINESSES THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY ENGAGE THAT
ACTIVITY.
AND TALK ABOUT HOW DO WE LIFTED
UP FROM A LOCAL.
PROGRAM TO SOMETHING THAT IS
SCALABLE STATEWIDE WHAT CAN WE
LEARN FROM ONE ANOTHER SO
INSTEAD OF IMPACTING A HUNDRED
OR THOUSAND STUDENTS WERE
ACTUALLY IMPACTING A HUNDRED AND
TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND WERE ABLE TO ACCELERATE IT
SO WE'RE NOT HAVING TO GO
COMPANY BY COMPANY BY COMPANY SO
IF THERE'S A WAY TO. AMPLIFY
WHAT'S GOING ON AND BRING MORE
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE AND AND I
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU IN
THE COMMITTEE IN THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO GET
THAT CONVERSATION GOING. BECAUSE
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE ON THE TABLE
OR PARK AT THE TABLE THEY WANT
TO BE HERE AND THAT'S JUST HOW
DO WE MAKE THAT EASY FOR THEM TO
ENGAGE AND AND AND HAVE THAT
COVERS.
WE ACCEPT YOUR OFFER MASSAGE.
BETTER FOR WHICH YOU HOUSE FOR.
ARE WE GOING TO MAKE IT SO THAT
OUR NEXT DAM HEARING IS REALLY
MORE FOCUS ON NOT HEARING.
BUT EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID.
HOW DO WE GET THOSE COMPANIES
THAT CURRENTLY ARE INVOLVED IN
THESE WAYS INVOLVED IN IT THAT
MEANS? LIFTING UP THE COMPANIES
THAT ARE PROVIDED.
YOU KNOW FROM THE EAST BAY
ETA'S AND.
THEM BRIDGE ABOUT TAKEN OTHERS
THAT WE CAN LIFT UP.
AND DO PEER MENTORSHIP BUSINESS
TO BUSINESS PEER MENTORSHIP TO
TALK ABOUT IT WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
WILL DO THAT SO WE ACCEPT YOUR
OFFER.
TO HELP AND THAT I KNOW THAT WE
CAN COUNT ON THIS ENTIRE PANEL
TO HELP HERE LOOSELY ABOUT.
AT AROUND THE TIME WE
DEVELOPING THE RACIAL SOME
ACTION PLAN ON MY EMPLOYER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHICH IS WITH
THE COMPRISED OF VERY PASSIONATE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT FUND AND
THEY'RE ENGAGED IN STEM
PROMOTION.
MET WITH CONGRESSWOMAN LEAN.
AND A WHAT WE DID IS WE COMPILED
FOR EACH COMPANY.
ALL THEIR OWN STEM PROGRAM AND
PUT IN A DIRECTORY FOR HER. AND
EACH OF THE REPRESENTATIVES WAS
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT WHY THEY
DEVELOP THIS PROGRAM WHAT IT
MEANS TO THEIR COMPANY AND
THEY'RE PLAYING GAUGE WENT.
I THINK THAT RECOGNITION FROM
LEGISLATORS GOES A LONG WAY WITH
THE COMPANIES
AND SO. IF THERE'S A WAY THAT.
THERE'S SOME KIND OF
RECOGNITION FROM THIS COMMITTEE
OR GREATER ASSEMBLY FOR
OUTSTANDING.
COMPANIES BIG AND SMALL WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN SOME PROMOTION AND
ENCOURAGING STEM JOBS ALL THAT
IS A WAY TO GET OTHER COMPANIES
INVOLVED AND ALSO WILL GET A
DIRECTORY OF GREAT BEST
PRACTICES FOR REPLICATION.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE EASY FOR
US TO DO YOU KNOW THERE ARE.
EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND.
FORTY SENATORS AND WE ALL CARE
ABOUT HIGHLIGHTING BUSINESSES
THAT ARE DOING GREAT THINGS IN
OUR COMMUNITY I THINK COULD BE
VERY EASY FOR US. TO PROVIDE
SOME RECOGNITION.
AND TO LIFT THEM UP IF YOU ALL
WOULD HELP US IDENTIFY THEM.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY VERY
EASY FOR US TO DO.
I ANYTHING FURTHER FROM THE
COMMITTEE A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA.
WELL I THINK WHEN I CAME AND I
WAS EXPECTING TO BE THINKING
ABOUT STEM.
AS THAT'S THE TITLE OR DOING
AND.
BUT IT REALLY DOES REMIND ME
ACTUALLY OF GOING BACKWARDS AND
I MANAGED IT OFF HAND BUT I
THINK IT COULD ACTUALLY BE A
SOLUTION TO WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS. TWENTY TWENTY YEARS
AGO IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE STATE ACTUALLY FUNDED
THROUGH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THROUGH A GRANT PROCESS. A
HEALTHY START COORDINATOR. AND
THE HEALTHY START COORDINATOR
LIKE I SAID WE'RE NOT FOCUSED ON
STARTING A NEW PROGRAM IT WAS
MAKING THOSE CONNECTIONS WITHIN
THEIR.
CITIES OR REGIONS AND FOR. MANY
OF THEM IT WAS OF COURSE YOU
KNOW LIKE I MENTIONED I GLASS
EXAMPLES BUT THERE'S ALSO
BUSINESSES AND OTHERS THAT WANT
LIKE YOU SAY THEY'RE THERE THEY
JUST DON'T KNOW HOW TO.
WHETHER IT BE CONTRIBUTE
WHETHER IT BE.
JOIN TOGETHER AND IN I THINK
THERE'S EXAMPLES EVERYWHERE OF
SOMEBODY'S ABLE TO GET.
PORT FOR A ONE TIME EVENT.
AND THEY WILL DO THAT BUT TO
REALLY.
MOVE FURTHER THAN THAT AND
BUILD A RELATIONSHIP AND HAS TO
BE KIND OF TWO FULL BECAUSE
OTHERWISE. IT'S LIKE CAN YOU
GIVE US THE US THEY DO AND THEN
YOU KNOW YOU'RE KIND OF DONE BUT
AS THE CHAIR OF THE JOBS
COMMITTEE. WE CONTINUE TO.
.
IT'S AN ODD LOOK AT YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THE FUTURE WORKFORCE
GONNA LOOK LIKE. AND ARE WE
PREPARING OUR STUDENTS FOR THOSE
FUTURE JOBS WE KNOW THAT. WE
ARE.
MOVING IN ONE WAY BUT THERE'S
OTHER AREAS WERE NOT DOING WELL
SO THERE'S BEEN A BIG EMPHASIS
ON. KIND OF RE LOOKING BACK AT
CT  WHICH IS A WHOLE NOTHER
CONVERSATION WE WON'T GET INTO
THAT.
BUT THE POINT IS NOT EVERYBODY'S
GOING TO GO DOWN ONE PASSED AWAY
AND STE TO MAKING SURE THAT
STUDENTS UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES WHETHER IT'S
THE TWO YEAR THE FOUR YEAR OR.
ARE PRACTICAL.
WELL PAIN PROFESSIONS
BUT
THERE COULD BE A SIDE
CONVERSATION AND ALL OF THIS IS
MAYBE WE REALLY DO LOOK MAYBE IT
ISN'T A HEALTHY START CAREER
COORDINATOR BUT MAYBE IT'S
SOMETHING. LIKE A NAVIGATOR THAT
COULD WORK THROUGH.
IN THAT CASE IT WAS OUT OF THAT
I THINK QUE EIGHT SCHOOLS OUT
WHERE THEY. MAY KNOW TEACHERS
WOULD APPLY BUT THEIR JOB WAS TO
REALLY BUILD A BUILD UP.
A COLLABORATIVE AND SO TWENTY
YEARS AGO WE STARTED THE FULLER
CHEN COLLABORATIVE AND THAT
STILL EXISTS.
SO THERE'S BEEN EVERYTHING FROM
YOU KNOW MAJOR GARDENING
PROJECTS TO LIKE I SAID UP
MEDICAL CLINIC BUT ALL TYPES OF
THINGS. BUT IT ISN'T JUST KINDA
NONPROFITS THAT HAVE AND THEN
BITE ITS LEADERS YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S THE LOCAL COUNCIL
SO THEY REALLY GET AND
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT ARE THE
NEEDS WHAT CAN WE DO. BUT YOU
COULD FOCUS AT MORNING BUSINESS
TYPE OF STEM FOCUS IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE. QUOTE HEALTH RELATED
OR HOLD PASSED IT
SO THAT COULD BE AN IDEA BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WAS BASICALLY PAYING. UP
THE SALARY FOR. AND I DON'T EVEN
THINK IT WAS EVERY DISTRICT I
THINK IT WAS THE DISTRICTS THAT
APPLIED. NAM I'M NOT SURE WHAT
IT COSTS THE STATE AND WHY THEY
STARTED DOING IT.
BUT.
DO YOU KNOW ANYBODY HERE NOW I
KNOW THAT THERE IS I I JUST
HEARD TODAY THERE'S A LETTER
CIRCULATING TO REQUEST A PILOT
TO REESTABLISH THE HEALTHY START
PROGRAM IT WOULD BE AT THE
AMOUNT OF TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND I KNOW THAT THE COALITION
THAT IS.
MOVING THIS FORWARD IS IS
LOOKING FOR OUT LEGISLATORS
WHO'D BE WILLING TO SIGN ON TO
THAT LETTER AND HELP TO. TO
BRING THAT EFFORT IRONING
SOMETHING AND SO.
MY STAFF HASN'T EVEN HEARD
ABOUT THIS ONE YET NOW BUT.
YOU KNOW WE COME OUT OFA
BACKGROUND OF WORKING WITH
HEALTHY START PROGRAMS THAT WE
THINK THAT THEY ARE EXCELLENT.
COMPLEMENT TO WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE AND STUFF. AND MAYBE
pHEALTHY START BECAUSE PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY THINK OF.
YOU KNOW HEALTH AS A BUT THE
IDEA IS HEALTH OF THE COMMUNITY.
AND YOU KNOW DO YOU HAVE GOOD
LIBRARIES DO YOU HAVE GOOD PARK
SPACE AND A HAVE AND THAT'S
WHERE THOSE. THOSE BRIDGES ARE
BILL BUT I COULD SEE THAT BEING
VERY EFFECTIVE SO THAT YOU COULD
BUILD COLLABORATIVE SO THAT THE
MODELS YOU'RE TRYING TO SHOW OR
EVEN WHAT YOU'VE DONE. YOU COULD
COME TO TALK TO THESE
COLLABORATIVE THAT HAVE BEEN
BUILT BECAUSE IT IS REALLY HARD
FOR PEOPLE TO COMMUNICATE.
STATEWIDE
I MEAN AS MUCH AS YOU TRY TO DO
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT BUT
GIVING PEOPLE. IN ESSENCE THE
TOOLS ARE THE BACKGROUND AND
THAT IT GIVE SOMEBODY A PLACE
TO.
MOVE TOWARDS.
I'LL JUST SAY THE LAST THING IS
I KNOW A LOT OF STUDENTS IN
HIGHER ED HAVE A REALLY
DIFFICULT TIME GETTING THE
INTERNSHIPS.
THAT THEY NEED THERE ARE MANY
OF THEM ARE REQUIRED IN THEIR
LAST YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL BUT
ALSO IN COLLEGE.
AND THAT EXPERIENCE IT SOUNDS
GRAY. EVERYBODY LOVES THE IDEA
BUT WHEN THEY'RE ACTUALLY
KNOCKING ON DOORS TO TRY TO GET
AN INTERNSHIP A IT'S NOT ONLY
VERY DIFFICULT BUT THEN
SOMETIMES SIX BARYONS. IS YOU
KNOW I'M ANSWERING PHONES ARE
FILING PAPERS SO I THINK THERE
COULD BE A LOT OF WORK DONE ON
THAT.
WE'RE THAT WE'RE GONNA BRING
THIS TO A CLOSE I AM AND I KNOW
THAT STUNNED MANY ON THIS PANEL
ARE DOING OTHER PANELS BECAUSE
I'M GONNA SEE SOME OF THEM IN
LESS THAN A MINUTE.
AND SPEAK ON THOSE PANELS BUT
NOT THIS YEAR SOME APPRECIATION
FOR THIS PANEL AND THE RICH
CONVERSATION.
THAT WE HAD.
.
AS ALWAYS I'M THANKFUL TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR REALLY PROMOTING
DEEP THOUGHT AND HOW WE THINK
BROADLY ABOUT HOW WE APPROACH
ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
THERE ARE NO SIMPLE EASY ISSUES
HERE BUT THEY'RE IMPORTANT
ISSUES FOR US TO WORK ON. NELSON
Y. KNOWLEDGE.
MY DISTRICT DIRECTOR OF SITTING
TO MY LEFT VERY NICELY AND MY
STAFF FOR ORGANIZING TODAY'S
HEARING AND UP FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO DIDN'T GET AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE'D ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE SPEAK WITH MISS
NICELY ABOUT THEM BECAUSE WE
CARE ABOUT WHAT YOU WANT US. TO
WORK ON NOT THANK YOU TO MY TEAM
INTO VERY NICELY ORGANIZING
TODAY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY YOU WERE VERY PATIENT AND
YOU STAYED WITH US OF FOR THE
DURATION OF THIS HEARING.
WE LOOK FOR TO THE ONGOING WORK
THAT WILL ALL TO TOGETHER OF
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU.
I'M HAPPY FOR IT.
YEAH